Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So
Hello
Was ist das für ein eisen musik das ist der auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf auf
Können wir kurz das hier hören?
Okay.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Oh, ich muss erstmal was trinken.
Ich bin ziemlich kaputt.
Ich bin
heute Morgen
46, also gestern
45 Minuten
gerannt.
Heute 46 Minuten.
Heute Morgen.
Und eben war ich nochmal
45 minuten unterwegs und mittlerweile ist richtig warm also im mittag bin ich
nur gelaufen also nicht nicht irgendwie schnell und ich habe ein bisschen zu
wenig getrunken das merke ich muss jetzt erst mal ein bisschen wasser auftanken
was macht eigentlich das sehr laut ist der eben ist er eben aufgeploppt
überhaupt beste startet
Okay, der Chat meint, ich soll mir das hier mal anhören.
Zeig mal her.
Boah.
geht finde ich jetzt nicht so übertrieben geil wobei ich sagen muss
nes musik finde ich auch teilweise etwas zu minimalistisch noch aber für nes
klingt das richtig gut
also für nes klingt das richtig gut
Aber so richtig mein Fall ist es nicht.
Aber für NES ist das richtig gut.
So, machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie was anderes an.
hier, keine Ahnung.
Kinder.
Mario Kart Musik geht immer.
Musik to refine to.
Also ehrlich, ich hab die erste und zweite Staffel
Severance geguckt.
Als ich's geguckt
habe, also gerade die erste Staffel,
war ich so extrem drauf
gehypt, was passiert.
Aber
im Nachhinein jetzt retrospektivisch
betrachtet, fand ich Severance doch nicht so geil.
Ich meine, es passiert halt einfach nix.
Und was die da treiben, weiß man bis zum
Ende der zweiten Staffel immer noch nicht. Also ich weiß
nicht.
Ja,
Es zieht sich, ne?
Ja, Chat.
Wisst ihr, was wir heute machen?
Heute machen wir wieder Server glücklich.
Gucken wir uns mal an, was es für neue
Aufgaben gibt.
Vorher muss ich aber mal schauen.
Ich habe vergessen,
mein Login mir hier aufzuschreiben.
Für Set-Servers.
Ich hoffe, ich hab das irgendwo
Wir müssen mal gleich gucken
Irgendwo in meinem Passwort-Safe
Weil ansonsten
Muss ich das Handy von der Arbeit holen
Und im Chat mit dem Azubi gucken
Dem hab ich nämlich mal den Zugang dazu geschickt
Also, rausfinden tun wir es auf jeden Fall
Aber ich muss erstmal Wasser auffüllen
Und Jet, was war bei euch so los die Woche?
Wobei das eigentlich meine Frage für Sonntag morgens immer ist
Irgendwas Spannendes passiert
Ich mach mal den Mini-PC an
Den brauchen wir jetzt gleich
Gyros
Ich habe heute
vegane Bolognese gefuttert
Also beziehungsweise Bolognese mit
veganem Hackfleisch drin
Der Rest ist ja an sich schon
Das war echt nicht schlecht
Das hat mehr oder weniger genauso geschmeckt wie
normales Hackfleisch.
Zumal das vom Hackfleisch in der Bolognese
eh nicht so viel schmeckt.
Schmeckt ja eher nach
Gewürzzeug und der Tomatensauce und allem.
Das ging schon klar.
So.
Wie gehst du mit Leuten um, die nichts können?
Ja, da gibt es halt jede Menge, das ist aber normal.
Und dich dann...
Ich bin ja sicherlich auch nicht perfekt.
Die nichts können und dich dann als Blocker bezeichnen,
obwohl die das selber fixen könnten
und ich Wichtigeres zu tun habe.
Okay, da musst du...
Das musst du jetzt ein bisschen konkreter beschreiben,
da kann ich mir jetzt wenig darunter vorstellen.
Leute, die nichts können,
Also Leute, die quasi, ah ok, ok, jetzt verstehe ich es. Du meinst jemand, der eigentlich dafür zuständig ist und es können müsste, sagt, du musst ihm helfen, sonst wird das nichts und du hast keinen Bock oder keine Zeit oder sonst was ihm gerade zu helfen und er sagt dann, er kann nichts machen, weil du ihm nicht hilfst.
So sinngemäß.
Boah.
Boah, schwierig.
Also geht's ja,
die Frage ist jetzt,
Die Frage ist jetzt
Inwieweit
Willst du in Zukunft noch mit dem
Gut zusammenarbeiten können oder nicht
Ganz ehrlich
Das einfachste ist, geh zu deinem Chef
Wenn du einen gescheiten Chef hast
Sag das deinem Chef
Sag hier, das ist dem sein Aufgabengebiet
Der erzählt überall rum
Ich müsste was machen
Stimmt aber überhaupt nicht
Und lass das deinem Chef klären
Du musst es nicht selbst klären.
Dann soll dein Chef zu dem
seinem Chef gehen.
Also wenn es dich so abfuckt,
geh zu deinem Chef.
Das ist bei sowas eigentlich immer
die einfachste Variante.
Weil oftmals
kommt ja auch nichts dabei rum,
wenn du dich mit den Leuten rumstreitest.
Und es ist gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn dein Chef das weiß im Vorfeld,
weil es könnte ja sein,
dass über fünf Ecken was bei ihm ankommt.
So nach dem Motto, guck mal hier,
er kümmert sich schon seit drei Wochen nicht drum,
mach mal was.
Geh zu deinem Chef.
Das ist bei vielen Sachen tatsächlich das Einfachste.
Und sag ihm, was Sache ist.
Es dürfte wahrscheinlich echt das Beste sein.
Wenn der Typ wirklich keine Ahnung hat, wird er es ja nicht machen können.
Und da wird nichts bei rauskommen.
Ich glaube, das Einfachste ist wirklich, du redest mit deinem Chef, sagst, hier, guck mal,
der Typ erzählt die ganze Zeit hier, ich müsste was machen, was eigentlich klar in seinem Aufgabengebiet liegt.
Und erzählt das jetzt auf irgendwelchen Meetings rum, das wirft ein schlechtes Licht auf uns, kannst du ja sagen.
Weil es wirft natürlich auch ein schlechtes Licht auf deinen Chef indirekt.
Und allein schon deswegen sollte dein Chef da Interesse dran haben, das dann zu klären.
So würde ich das machen.
Hattest du Kuchen und Süßkran an deinem ersten Arbeitsabend mitgebracht?
Nö.
Nee.
Hätte ich sollen?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe am...
Vor...
Ich glaube vorletztes Weihnachten oder so...
hab ich mal was mitgebracht.
Vorletzten Weihnachten
hab ich mal Dings hier mitgebracht
auf die Arbeit.
Das hier.
Das ist richtig nice.
Ja Gott, das Abbild.
Was sagst du?
Wär das nicht sinnvoll?
Wenn du da einfach mal mit deinem Chef drüber redest?
Guck mal hier, dass es
mega nice ist, was die haben
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder?
Ja, Fabrikverkauf
Ja, excellent
Ja
60er Karton, bam
Die sind
Exzellent
Also ich esse am liebsten
Die hier
Die zwei, die zwei
Die sind pock
Auch wenn ich normalerweise nichts Alkoholisches großartig zu mir nehme
Die schmecken aber richtig gut hier
Die zwei, beste hier
Warum es keine 64er Kartons gibt
Weil normale Leute nicht in 2% zählen.
Die sind auch geil.
Die sind auch mega nice.
Also Kokosweiß habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Aber hier.
Aber die sind auch mega nice.
Ich wollte hier auch mal Eis essen bei denen.
Da war eine Schlange bis zum Ausgang vom Parkplatz.
Da habe ich gesagt, nee, ich stelle mich da jetzt bestimmt keine halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten an nur für Eis.
Warte mal.
So.
Exzellent.
Oh, ich hasse dieses Wort, Alter.
Weaponized Incompetence.
Das ist so ein...
So ein Spruch.
So ein Reddit-Spruch ist das.
Das ist so ein Reddit-Spruch.
Es gibt halt Leute, die können halt wirklich einfache Sachen nicht.
Ich glaube, jeder von uns kann ernsthaft auch für andere Leute super einfache Dinger nicht.
Da gab es doch letztens so einen riesen Aufreger.
Ich weiß nicht mal.
Ich habe die Dokumentation nicht geguckt.
Es gab wohl irgendeine Dokumentation
über irgendeinen Profifußballer.
Und
der stand dann wohl im Supermarkt und wusste nicht,
welche Kartoffeln er kaufen soll.
Und da hat sich Reddit wieder
aufgeregt, Alter. Wie kann
das sein, dass der Profifußballer
nicht weiß, dass man
irgendwie
weichkochende und hartkochende und mehlige
und sonst was Kartoffeln... Keine Ahnung,
welcher Fußballer das war. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
Alter, was wollt ihr denn Reddit, Mann?
Der Kerl ist Profifußballer.
Der geht nicht selbst einkaufen normalerweise.
Ja.
Der hat andere Probleme.
Ich glaube, bei vielen Leuten auf Reddit ist das dann auch so.
Ey, guck mal.
Das ist einer.
Der hat viel mehr Geld als ich.
Der ist viel erfolgreicher als ich.
Aber diese Sache kann ich.
Die kann er nicht.
Da muss ich mich jetzt drüber aufregen, wie lächerlich das ist auf Reddit.
Dass der was kann, was nicht kann, was ich kann, so nach dem Motto.
Also Reddit ist da teilweise echt Painstamp.
Irgendwie ist wieder das Headset auf der einen Seite...
Wartet mal, ich muss das...
Also entweder ist mal wieder mein Ohr, was auf der rechten Seite nicht so gut hört wie auf der linken.
Oder mein... Aber mein Headset ist gar nicht groß verknotet.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich war's es nicht.
Ja, Gottes Appelt, was sagst du denn zu meiner Sache, dass du jetzt am besten mit deinem Chef bereden solltest?
Das würde mich jetzt natürlich schon interessieren, nachdem du gefragt hast.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist die beste Variante.
Ich habe es ja eben lang und breit erklärt, warum ich das denke.
So.
Login.
Chat, ihr müsst jetzt kurz weggucken.
Nicht wundern.
Ich muss mal kurz...
Ah, Moment, ich muss
Inkognito.
Datenfenster.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Zeigt die URL.
Ne, ich werde die URL nicht zeigen.
Weil
diesmal machen wir das mit dem Command Line Tool
von denen.
Die haben nämlich jetzt ein Command Line Tool.
So, Leute.
Ich habe hier ein
leider etwas zu langes Passwort.
Deswegen dauert es kurz, bis ich fertig getippt habe.
Ich hoffe, es hat jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, okay. Hat funktioniert.
Exzellent. So, jetzt gibt es gleich
wieder Bild.
Zack.
Da sind wir.
Chat.
Da sind wir eingeloggt.
Was haben wir denn schon alles erledigt hier?
Das haben wir alles erledigt.
Das haben wir noch...
Die haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Das ist neu.
Glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das ist neu.
Das ist easy.
Haben wir alles gemacht.
Hier haben wir noch ein paar Easy-Sachen.
Hier haben wir auch schon ein paar Medium-Sachen erledigt.
Schwere.
Also wir haben schon ganz viele davon gemacht vor drei Jahren oder so.
Aber mit dem Account noch nicht.
Vor allem habe ich jetzt ja auch ein Premium-Account.
Und angeblich haben die jetzt, ich zeige es euch mal,
Documentation
CLI. Guck mal, die haben
jetzt ein CLI-Tool, da kann man da drauf
zugreifen. Das ist eigentlich richtig nice.
Dann leake ich
nichts mehr.
Aber ich muss mich erstmal wieder, ich muss erstmal
in der richtigen Stimmung
sein jetzt, zu Server administraten.
Hm.
Und mir ist das mit auf der einen Seite höheren Windlautstärke auch echt...
Lautstärke-Slider bewegen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das jetzt was gebracht hat.
Schreib's dir auf.
Schreib's dir einfach auf.
Das macht auch nichts, wenn du da auf deinen Zettel guckst.
Kannst du deinem Chef sagen, hier, dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Ich hab mir das mal aufgeschrieben.
Wir müssen mal hier über was reden.
Am besten natürlich, ne,
jetzt nicht mitten im Büro, wo fünf andere Leute
auch noch dabei sitzen und
dann alle was zu sagen wollen oder so.
Sag einfach hier, wir müssen mal kurz über was reden.
Und dann passt das.
Kannst du ja ruhig aufschreiben.
Denk einfach kurz an C++, dann kommt die Motivation von ganz alleine.
Ich habe letztens ein C++ Video gesehen.
Das hieß irgendwie was, das beste C++ Feature oder so.
Da musste ich mir echt wieder krass an den Kopf greifen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Video jetzt finde.
Best C++
Feature
hieß das.
How C++
took a turn for the first year.
Boah, da könnte ich mich natürlich auch
jetzt wieder reinsteigern.
Lass mal gucken, man kann den Kram doch hier sortieren
Nach
Ist innerhalb des letzten Monats hochgeladen
Most important feature
Genau, ich glaub, ich glaub das hier
Und ohne Scheiß, also erstens mal keine Ahnung
Was das für ein komisches
Farbschema ist, aber seriously
Was zum Teufel
Warum, Chat
Warum
Warum ist diese Syntax ein Ding?
Ich weiß, das ist für Reflection und alles.
Wir haben uns das schon mal angeguckt.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich diese Syntax sehe,
da muss ich auch kotzen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist das?
The fuck, Alter?
Das hier geht ja alles noch irgendwie.
Das hier geht...
Wenn C++ eine CagW-Syntax bekommt...
Ey, C++ hat enorm viel CagW-Syntax.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich auch witzig finde?
C++ hat seit, ich glaube, C++ 22, 21, gell, gibt es, oder?
Ne, 21, oder? C++ 21.
Seit C++ 21 gibt es Standardprintf oder Standardprint, Standardprint.
da kann man, also man kann ja
in C++ erst seit
3-4 Jahren oder so
ordentlich Strings formatieren, das ging ja
vorher nicht, vorher gab es
nur diese Standard C-Out Variante
das gibt es ja erst
seit irgendwie 3-4 Jahren
also ich meine, standardisiert wurde das schon ein bisschen
länger, aber
das meine ich nicht
fmt print
Ja.
Guck.
Beispiele sind halt auch wieder absolut lächerlich.
Guck, das geht erst.
Das geht erst seit C++.
Ach, erst seit 23.
Ach, erst seit 23 ist das sogar so.
Es heißt im Endeffekt,
man kann das realistisch erst seit
1-2 Jahren benutzen.
Weil das muss ja dann immer auch noch von allen möglichen
Compiler und Plattformen unterstützt werden.
Guck mal, man kann
jetzt in C++
Strings so formatieren, wie in
jeder anderen ordentlichen Programmiersprache
seit ungefähr
30 Jahren.
26 Jahren.
Seit 2000
oder so.
Oder sag mal seit
20 Jahren, okay?
Mittlerweile
Mittlerweile sind moderne Programmiersprachen sogar noch ein ganzes Stück weiter.
Da gibt es nicht mehr einfach nur dieses 0. Feld, 1. Feld, 2. Feld und dann hinten die Argumente einsetzen,
sondern mittlerweile kann man ja in vielen Programmiersprachen sowas hier sinngemäß machen.
guckt, dass ich dann sage,
also anstatt
hier diesen Kram so zu schreiben,
dass ich dann hier sage, äh,
Name,
Age,
äh, keine Ahnung, Student, so war es
auch immer so. Ja, das kann man in vielen Programmen
hier sprechen, auch mal. Und ich finde, das hier
ist eigentlich die beste Variante.
Ja, das haben die sich auch
ganz hart von der Python-Syntax abgeguckt.
Ich glaube, dass,
ich glaube, das sagt der Erfinder
dieses C++-Moduls
sogar, dass sie, genau,
die sagen Format, String, Syntax,
similar to Python's Format.
Ah!
Das ist ja auch wieder C++-Logik.
Hier, guckt mal. Standardformat
gab es in C++20.
Standardprint
gibt es erst in C++23.
Das heißt, die haben drei Jahre gebraucht,
um auf die chlorreiche Idee
zu kommen. Man möchte nicht nur
Strings mit dieser Syntax formatieren,
sondern möchte vielleicht auch Strings mit dieser
Syntax printen.
Warum?
Warum? Warum brauchen die da drei
Jahre für?
Ist das nicht das naheliegendste auf der Welt?
Wenn man eine gute Syntax hat, um Strings zu
erzeugen, dass man die vielleicht auch printen will?
Ich meine, man konnte die natürlich über
Umwege printen, indem man als erstes mit Standardformaten
eine Variable schreibt oder Standardformaten
rappt in einem Print oder so, aber
C++, Alter.
Okay.
Ja, und jetzt haben sie
diese hässliche...
Ich meine, was ist das hier?
Was zum Teufel ist das hier wieder für eine
Syntax, Mann?
Und das ist jetzt noch ganz gut lesbar.
Stand-up.
Und by the way, das ist auch sowas, was mich in C++ übelst aufregt.
Die haben 30.000 Funktionen und Sachen da drin.
Aber alles gammelt irgendwie in dem SCD-Namespace drin rum.
Okay, aber genug C++ Rage.
Das reicht jetzt.
Das war jetzt einfach nur,
dass ich ein bisschen in Schwung komme, okay?
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein Knopf
bei mir im Stream?
Ah, da kann ich irgendwie in meinem eigenen Stream joinen.
Sehr sinnvoll.
Du meinst das hier?
Das ist das Astriquarium.
Das Beste.
Guck mal, du kannst sogar schneller laufen lassen.
Einfache Geschwindigkeit, doppelte Geschwindigkeit.
Und dann siehst du, dass ab und zu mal
irgendwann ein Hai vorbeikommt und auch Fische frisst.
Der ist aber selten.
Also der Hai kommt wirklich selten.
Ist auch gut, sonst wären die ja alle weg.
Ups.
Schiffe fahren auch vorbei.
Große Fische, kleine Fische, geangelt.
Und irgendwann...
Timmy, Timmy gibt's auch.
Haben wir Timmy schon gesehen?
Timmy schwimmt auch manchmal vorbei.
Da, da ist er, guck.
Werbung.
Ja, das mach ich, wenn der Stream dann ordentlich läuft.
Da, hier, da ist der Hai.
Die Fische hatten aber Glück, der Hai ist oft kein Fisch.
Der frisst die dann auch, wenn die auf der gleichen Ebene schwimmen.
Wie kann ich...
Dankeschön für den Sub, by the way.
Pog.
Wie kann ich sinnvoll sagen, dass ich mich als 20-Stunden-Werkstudent nicht auf 2,5 Projekte,
Team Tech Support und 8 Stunden
Meetings pro Woche. Was?
Fragen, ob da
eine Vollzeit-Junior-Stelle drin wäre.
Ja, kannst du überhaupt eine Vollzeit-Junior-Stelle
machen? Du studierst doch gerade noch.
Sinux, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente
Subscriptions, Leute.
Wo habe ich die...
Ah, ich bin noch eingeloggt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Documentation, CLI.
Ja, ich würde mir da auch nicht so viele Gedanken machen.
Ich würde das vielleicht umdrehen.
Ich würde den fragen, wie es hier mit Juniorstellen aktuell aussieht.
Weil du machst ja jetzt schon quasi so viel Zeug.
Das kriegst du gar nicht alles in deine 20-Stunden-Woche rein.
Du hättest ja auch Bock drauf, mehr zu machen.
Aber es geht halt gerade nicht.
Also Arbeit ist genug da.
So in der Richtung vielleicht.
Wie sieht es hier aus mit Juniorstellen?
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt in zweieinhalb Projekten.
Zahlen viele Meetings.
machen auch technik support nebenbei das haut alles nicht hin
die suchen nach einem senior sollen sich nicht so anstellen die sollen auch
juniors nehmen wie sollen juniors jemals zu seniors werden wenn die leute nur
noch seniors einstellen da fragt halt dann fragt halt einfach nicht nach einer
junior stelle und sagt einfach wie sieht es mit einer normalen stelle aus
weil du kennst dich ja da anscheinend schon ein bisschen aus.
AI keck weh.
Oh man, jetzt fühlt er sich geil oder?
Warte mal.
Ah, zack.
Weg.
Vorher war er bestimmt auf Reddit.
Genau.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, die kennen dich doch schon.
Und, und, und, und, weiß ich nicht.
Ich würde mir nicht jedes Mal so viel Gedanken drüber machen.
Ich weiß, das ist super einfach gesagt.
Das ist schwer umzusetzen.
Wahrscheinlich C++-Fan gewesen.
Ich würde mir da nicht jedes Mal so Gedanken drüber machen,
weil ich erzähle immer was.
Du machst ja so viele Gedanken mit,
ich kann mich schlecht ausdrücken.
Ich erzähle dir was.
Und zwar, ich habe früher in der Schule
und allgemein habe ich extrem ungern Präsentationen gemacht.
Und das hat dazu geführt,
dass ich mich mit dem Thema, wenn wieder sowas angestanden hat, nie beschäftigt habe.
Weil ich habe mir gedacht, die Präsentation wird eh scheiße, du hast da keinen Bock drauf
und deswegen beschäftigst du dich am besten gar nicht damit.
So, und das habe ich gemacht und das hat dann dazu geführt,
dass die Präsentation auch immer beschissen geworden ist.
So quasi selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung.
Ich bin davon ausgegangen, die wird beschissen sein.
Ich habe deswegen in der Richtung quasi nichts gemacht und dann wurde sie auch beschissen.
Das heißt, umso mehr man sich Gedanken um die ganze Geschichte macht,
umso mehr du dir Gedanken darüber machst, so nach dem Motto,
oh, das kommt jetzt bestimmt eh falsch an, weil ich kann das ja alles nicht gut ausdrücken.
Umso mehr sorgst du eigentlich dafür, dass es so wird.
und wenn du dir nicht alles merken kannst
oder nervös bist, dann schreib dir
was auf, das ist eh das Beste, weil
also man denkt ja,
das wirkt dann blöd, aber ab und zu auf den Zettel gucken
ist überhaupt nicht schlimm, weil es ist ganz
normal, dass wenn man aufgeregt ist,
da muss man sich überhaupt keine Gedanken machen,
sobald du richtig aufgeregt bist, kannst
du nicht mehr richtig denken, das ist normal.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
evolutionstechnisch, kann man das bestimmt auch
erklären, ja, aber du kannst nicht
mehr denken, wenn du aufgeregt bist, das geht
nicht.
Oder zumindest nicht mehr gut.
Deswegen ist Aufschreiben nicht verkehrt.
Dann hast du dann was, wenn du den Faden
verlierst, wo du nachgucken kannst.
Ja, genau. Ich finde das auch
überhaupt nicht schlecht, wenn die Leute sich was aufschreiben.
Also, ich meine,
Nicht, dass ich in irgendeiner Position wäre, wo das relevant wäre.
Nee, ich meine nur, also, ich finde, das würde ich auch machen, ja.
Ich schreibe mir auch oft auf dem Handy was auf und sage dann hier,
ich muss mal kurz aufs Handy gucken, dass ich nichts vergesse.
Das hat mir noch nie einer krumm genommen.
Ja.
So, dann würde ich sagen, legen wir mal los, oder?
Set Server Command Line Interface gibt es jetzt.
Das heißt, man kann nicht nur hier das Ganze...
Chat, soll ich vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was das ist?
Bevor wir anfangen.
Ich erkläre das nochmal, okay?
Weil anhand des Titels erkennt man es nicht so wirklich.
Das machen wir vielleicht in den Titel.
Erstmal Dark Mode, ja, hast du recht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt.
Was ist das da für ein Knopf eigentlich?
Ah, Private Session Clear.
Ne, will ich nicht.
Ja, den Titel noch mal angepasst.
So.
Jetzt muss ich mir mal kurz was überlegen.
Wenn wir das jetzt nämlich im Browser aufmachen,
muss ich...
Kann man irgendwie sagen,
in KDE.
Ich will dieses A hier.
Above Others.
Okay.
Jetzt testen wir mal was.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
Ob wir das hinkriegen
Ups
Es muss ja nur hier
Hier versteckt sein
Okay
Ich zeige euch mal wie das ganze funktioniert
Das müsste ein Schlamm
Also es gibt hier
Eine Aufgabe
eine liste mit aufgaben nennt nennt sich szenarios die sind eingeteilt in easy medium und schwer
sondern es gibt total viele mittlerweile kommt es gibt 30 easy szenarios mittlerweile 68 glücklicherweise
mittlere szenarios ich glaube 18 19 hier schweres szenarios und bei jedem szenario kriegst du ein
linux server oder den kubernetes cluster oder sagen wir mal irgendwas was mit linux zu tun hat
mit einer Aufgabe dabei.
Guck, wenn man das hier jetzt anklickt, steht da.
Also das ist Aufgabe Nummer 1 bei Easy.
Die ist auch wirklich easy.
Da kriegst du hier eine Aufgabenbeschreibung.
Und zwar, ein Entwickler hat ein Testprogramm erstellt,
was kontinuierlich nach Warlock, Badlock schreibt
und die Festplatte voll macht.
So, das kann man so und so überprüfen.
Das Programm braucht man nicht mehr.
Ich soll gucken, dass ich das beende.
Aber ohne das Lockpfeil zu löschen
Das ist
Das ist mega nice
Es gibt ein Premium
Premium
Bundle
Oder wie man das nennt
Es gibt
Pro und Pro Plus
Das hier, da kannst du nämlich auch Invitation-Links verschicken.
Invitations, Invitations.
Also Einladungs-Links verschicken.
Das ist mega nice für Vorstellungsgespräche zum Beispiel.
Also wenn, bei, also oder halt auch, also wenn du sowas machen musst, ja.
Oder für deinen Chef.
Das heißt, wenn beispielsweise Linux-Admins eingestellt werden sollen.
Oder irgendwelche Leute, die was mit Linux zu tun haben.
und du willst halt auch mal checken, dass die nicht nur labern,
dann kannst du denen einfach hier einen Invitelink zu einem Szenario schicken und sagen, mach mal.
Das ist eigentlich richtig nice.
Also ganz ehrlich, und die Aufgaben sind nicht schlecht.
Du brauchst übrigens, wenn du einfach nur mal ausprobieren willst,
brauchst du weder noch...
Guck mal, die sind alle...
Alle Szenarien kann jeder machen, kostenlos.
Nur die, wo Pro dran steht, brauchen eine Subscription.
Und ich finde, das ist echt ganz fair.
Also du kannst, würde ich mal sagen, die Hälfte...
Die Hälfte der Szenarios kannst du machen.
By the way, früher war noch mehr kostenlos.
Also das ist...
Ich finde das wirklich super.
Wir haben das damals schon mal gemacht.
Da war das noch ganz neu.
Da hat das, da hat das keine Ahnung, nur 20 Aufgaben oder so.
Also wir haben das vor 3 oder 4 Jahren schon gemacht.
Mittlerweile ist das ja richtig groß und anscheinend.
Und was ich cool finde, dass die mittlerweile quasi auch einen Bütsnitz dahinter haben.
Finde ich mega nice.
So, und das Ganze funktioniert.
folgendermaßen kriegst du eine Aufgabe hier, so nach dem Motto,
sollst du das Programm finden und beenden.
Wie macht man das?
Meinst du, das würde helfen, an eine Defop-Stelle
zu kommen? Also für den
Skillaufbau auf jeden Fall.
Ob das
auf irgendeiner Skill-Liste oder so
Anklang findet,
hängt halt ein bisschen davon ab, ob die das kennen.
Wir hatten mal einen,
Das fand ich auch lustig. Bei der alten Arbeit hatten wir mal einen Bewerber, der hatte in seinem Skill-Profil irgendwie drin stehen, keine Ahnung, 5 Jahre Erfahrung vor M-Ware, 5 Jahre Erfahrung Ubuntu oder Linux und sowas.
Und da kam dann am Ende raus, der hatte mal Ubuntu auf Vmware Workstation installiert, vor 5 Jahren.
Das waren seine einzigen Kenntnisse in dem Bereich.
Und er war ganz überrascht, dass das überhaupt da steht.
Und dann hat sich im Nachhinein rausgestellt, er hat das nie selbst geschrieben, dieser Recruiter-Typ hat einfach massiv den Lebenslauf frisiert.
So mit allem.
Also er hat dann aus, ich habe vor 5 Jahren mal Ubuntu in VMware installiert, hat er gemacht 5 Jahre Ubuntu, Linux und VMware Erfahrung.
Die sind da hart drauf.
Ah ja, da geht es um Provision, ja.
So, zumindest, wir machen jetzt mal die erste Aufgabe so als Beispiel.
Das hier ist die Problembeschreibung
Hier läuft quasi ein Programm drauf, was die Festplatte vollmüllt
Und wir sollen das beten
Klickt man hier auf Run
Und man kriegt jetzt eine richtig echte
Neuprofessionierte
Ich glaube bei AWS läuft das
Linux VM
Also das ist kein
Nachgebautes Linux oder sowas
Nur für, oder so keine
Sandbox
Wie das manche
Das ist kein Packet Tracer
oder sowas. Das ist wirklich eine richtig echte
Deluxe-VM, die eben kaputt ist. Im Hintergrund
wird das bei AWS
glaube ich eine VM erzeugt
und
dann mit Ansible das Ding aufgebaut.
Es gibt sogar auf
Es gibt sogar auf GitHub
glaube ich gab es mal
Okay
Ich bilde mir ein, es gab mal sogar
Ansible-Files hier.
Aber gibt's, glaube ich,
nicht mehr.
Deswegen dauert es auch
kurz, bis die VM da ist.
Auf Bord-Servern
übt es sich am besten.
Ich hab letztens auf
Verlangen eines
Anwendungsbetreibers bei uns
das Log-Level in Produktion auf
Debug hochgesetzt.
Und es hat irgendwie 15 Sekunden gedauert.
Dann waren die 6 GB
voll.
Bam!
Das hat so krass gelockt.
Das war eine Springboot-Anwendung.
Und die hat so
hardcore gelockt,
dass das in,
keine Ahnung, 15, 20 Sekunden war die Platte voll.
so wird es auch geben aber wir haben das server terminal auf hack alter chat wenn
ich das hier kopiere wenn ich das hier kopiere mal gucken ob das immer noch ein
problem ist dass man da hinkommt
ja ok ist alles aber wo der chat wieder komische dinge anstellt ich muss diese
Ich muss die URL irgendwie verstecken.
Das Problem ist, das funzt nicht.
Okay, was wir noch ausprobieren können ist,
per SSH.
Mein Problem ist, ich glaube, ich habe den SSH-Key nicht,
den ich dafür brauche.
Aber das ist kein Problem, den können wir doch hinzufügen, oder?
Den da.
Den können wir im Dashboard hinzufügen
Aber wenn ich ins Dashboard gehe, Chat, muss ich euch mal kurz ausmachen
Oder versprecht ihr mir nicht zu gucken
Ihr guckt nicht, oder, Chat? Ihr guckt nicht
Ich mach euch wieder an
Ich find die Simoes so geil, Alter.
So.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert per SSH.
Aber ich will eh das Command Line Tool von denen ausprobieren.
Na auf.
Create mal die VM.
Ihr dürft euch dann übrigens aussuchen, welches Szenario wir machen.
Da sind wir.
So, schauen wir mal.
Yes.
Moment.
Leak ich jetzt meine IP, wenn ich mich da drauf einlogge?
Sekunde.
Keck, wait.
Dass das alles immer so kompliziert sein muss.
Äh, okay.
Permission denied.
Es funktioniert noch nicht mal, okay.
Ich habe meinen SSH-Key aber da hinzugefügt.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Wir machen das, Leute, wir machen das
mit dem CLI-Tool.
Wir machen das jetzt mit dem CLI-Tool
von denen. Mal gucken,
ob das besser ist.
Ja, ähm,
Documentation,
CLI-Tool. Ja, das ist halt kacke,
dass das Fenster immer so dumm aufgeht.
So, CLI Tools. Hier gibt es das zum Runterladen.
AMD 64.
Copy Link.
Gehen wir mal nach Downloads oder so.
Beget.
CHMOD plus X.
Sets.
Ups.
Sets. Und jetzt muss man was machen?
Off.
Open this all in your browser to authenticate.
Okay.
Chatge.
Ich muss euch schon wieder ausmachen.
Wer weiß, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich es in den Browser eingib.
Authorize CLI access.
Set server CLI approved.
Okay.
Hat funktioniert.
Escape, Leute. Escape.
Da sind wir.
So, und jetzt Type Scenarios.
Also jetzt sage ich
Set
Scenarios
Achso.
Was soll ich vielleicht richtig schreiben?
So, man konnte doch auch
irgendwie so einen GUI anzeigen.
Status.
Is running.
Okay.
Sets SSH.
Heute müsste er aber echt leiden.
Was SSH?
Oh Gott.
Das Problem ist...
Ähm...
Chat, das Problem ist...
Das mit SSH-Connection funktioniert nicht.
Das ist natürlich sehr unpraktisch.
Ich könnte mir einen neuen Key generieren.
Vielleicht hat er Probleme mit...
...mit den Keys.
Okay.
SSH-Keygen.
Wir generieren uns jetzt einen RSA-Key.
SSH Keygen.
Okay.
Ja, ja.
Probieren wir mal.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Yes.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal.
Config.
Und jetzt
EDRSA.
Das hätte ich im Vorfeld machen sollen.
Da muss ich euch nicht laufend ausmachen.
Es geht einfach nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Ich hinterlege jetzt mal den Public Key nochmal im Webinterface extra.
Wenn es da nicht geht, müssen wir es über den Browser machen.
Na?
Chat?
Es funzt nicht.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Das ist schon die erste Challenge, ja.
Ne, das ist kaputt.
Das geht nicht.
Okay, dann müssen wir es irgendwie anders machen.
Dann machen wir Browserfenster auf.
Konnte man...
Chat, ich brauche jetzt mal die KDE-Kenner.
KDE, High IQ KDE-Checkers.
Konnte man nicht bei KDE...
das Ding hier in den Desktop
irgendwie in den Tiling-Modus versetzen.
Das ging doch irgendwie.
Dass man jetzt irgendwie sagt hier...
Ja, nee.
Ich halte das, dass es gleich schon teilt.
Tealit.
Das heißt Tealit.
Mal gucken, ob ich schnell genug bin
Bam
Chat, ich glaube, ich hab's
Glaub ich hab's gepackt
Ich muss jetzt nur noch mal eine Sache gucken
Ich muss einfach schnell sein
Oh, for fuck's sake, Alter
Chat
Guck mal.
Das da oben,
das da oben,
ist die gleiche ID wie hier.
WTF?
Destroy Server, bam.
Okay, wir müssen das irgendwie hinkriegen.
Also das heißt,
wir müssen das so machen.
So, okay, okay
Starten
Run
Also das Problem ist
Das Problem ist, dass jeder im Stream
Der die URL hat, sich da einloggen kann
Das ist halt etwas unpraktisch
Und das ist insofern unpraktisch
Die Leute machen halt den Server kaputt
Und ich wundere mich, woran es liegt
Das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie fixen
Weißt du, was wir machen?
Oder du machst kurz schwarz, wenn du das Fenster eröffnest und packst was drüber
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Ich glaube, so machen wir das.
Ich mache kurz schwarz, schiebe das hinter das Terminal und dann ist gut.
Ja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die einfachste Variante.
Das Problem hatten wir bei dem Tiling Window Manager nie.
Bei dem Tiling Window Manager ist immer das Fenster richtig aufgegangen.
Okay, Chat.
Gut.
Wir sind wieder am Start.
Da sind wir wieder.
Äh.
Sag mal, kann das sein,
dass Setsauvers gerade kaputt ist?
Weil guckt mal, Leute
Ich krieg
Keine SSH
Ah, jetzt, okay
Ah
Vielleicht hab ich nicht lange genug gefahren
Was auch immer
Aber hier sind wir
Nee, Chat
Ist die ID das gleiche wie im Fenster?
Dann rast dich aus
Wie soll ich das jetzt benutzen überhaupt?
Wie soll ich das jetzt benutzen?
Das haben die geändert.
Das war früher nicht der Fall.
Ja, fuck.
Und jetzt?
Wie soll ich das jetzt benutzen?
Keine Ahnung.
Fällt uns da irgendwas Schlaues ein?
Dem Chat trusten?
Der Chat kann sich nicht zurückhalten.
Ich kenne den Chat.
Das klappt nicht.
Okay, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Ich muss euch nochmal kurz ausmachen,
und mal ins Dashboard gucken, was man da so machen kann.
SSH-Keys hinzufügen.
Invitations
brauchen wir nicht. Organization.
Saved Running.
Servers Achievement.
Ja, fuck.
Es gibt...
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
Ja, das ist ja richtig räulich
Warum haben die das denn so gemacht?
Das war früher nicht so
Früher hieß das Ding Linux VM oder so
Hausname ändern
Da musst du dich ausloggen und rebooten
Im Zweifelsfall, dass es überall greift
Ich kann das Ding nicht rebooten, dann ist er weg
Ey, keine Ahnung
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wie wir das machen sollen
Chat, ich starte das jetzt mal
und ihr macht einfach nichts, okay?
Und wenn es nicht klappt,
hör mal auf.
Also, scheiß drauf.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Erste, der das in letzter Zeit streamen will.
Doch, denke ich schon.
Chat, wir können ja gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das denn überhaupt funktioniert.
Oder ob ich mir umsonst Gedanken mache.
Der Shellprompt könnte ich ändern.
Ja, aber das kann doch alles nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein.
Chat, wir können es jetzt so machen. Probiert mal aus, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Probiert mal aus gleich, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ob ihr dann auf dem Server rauskommt.
In OBS oben und links was drüber.
Das Problem ist, dass jede Zeile enthält den Hausnamen.
Das ist halt richtig dumm.
So.
Ach guckte mal!
Copy the key below to SSH...
Ach so!
Moment, you can also set a public SSH-Key in your Dashboard with Pod.
Ja, das habe ich doch.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Na gut, also ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich weiß, ihr könnt...
Irgendwann ist es dann mal gestartet.
Also mit
mit Keys
mit SSH Keys hat das ja
bisher
nicht funktioniert
Yes
Ha
Geil
Und ich habe meine Public-IP nicht geleakt.
Ja, das ist praktisch.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Das geht über den SSH-Proxy.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, alles gut, Chatge.
Alles gut.
Wir können es doch ausprobieren.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Excellent.
Also, jetzt zeige ich euch das Ganze mal.
Also das hier ist die Aufgabe im Endeffekt.
Das ist die erste Aufgabe unter Easy.
Also die ist auch wirklich easy.
Nur dass ihr jetzt mal gesehen habt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Also es gibt im Endeffekt hier ein Log-File.
Da schreibt ein Programm die ganze Zeit rein.
Und wir sollen das Programm beenden.
Ups.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Äh, Axel, was meinst du?
Das sehe ich hier nicht.
Naja, zumindest...
Zumindest ist jetzt halt die Aufgabe, wir müssen das Programm beenden.
und das kann man dann unter den jungs sagt man einfach ls oft gibt es lockt an sieht welcher
prozess auf die sache zugreift gilt dann die pitt also gilt was ich das programm was darauf
zugreift guck passiert nicht ist nichts mehr und dann kann man hier unten sagen check my
solution und dann sagt er beim x solution ist erfolgreich so funktioniert das was im
Schnelldurchgang. Szenario 1. Easy.
Eats.
Eats AF.
Okay, weiter. Szenarios.
So, Chat. Jetzt dürft ihr euch
ein Szenario aussuchen. Wir probieren
das nochmal hier mit
Sets. UI.
Was?
Szenarios.
Okay.
Wir machen das anders.
Wir benutzen nicht das UI.
Wir loggen uns einfach PS1-H da drauf ein.
So, Chat, ihr könnt euch jetzt das Szenario raussuchen,
was wir machen wollen.
Also wir nehmen natürlich irgendein Szenario,
was wir noch nicht haben.
Oder was haltet ihr davon,
wenn wir erstmal
die Easy-Dinger fertig machen?
Alle.
Da fehlt ja nicht mal viel.
Komm, wir machen erstmal die Easy-Dinger fertig.
So ein bisschen zum Aufwärmen.
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Generate new SSL Certificate.
Also, Description.
Description.
Alter.
Auf diesem Rechner läuft ein Engine...
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
So, viel besser schon, oder? Viel besser.
Auf diesem Rechner läuft ein Nginx-Webserver, der so konfiguriert ist, dass er eine einfache Hello-World-Seite über HTTPS bereitstellt.
Das SSL-Zertifikat ist jedoch abgelaufen.
Erstellen Sie ein neues SSL-Zertifikat für den Nginx-Webserver mit dem selben Aussteller und derselben Betreffperson gleich.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Zertifikatshandling ist PainsChamp hoch 10.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich das auf die Reihe kriege.
Es kann sein, dass ich da schon bei Easy versage.
Da braucht man quasi einen CSR.
Und dann...
Ne, Chat-GPT.
Ja, wir machen das einfach mal.
So, also das ist Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Können wir uns angucken?
Wir verbinden uns jetzt einfach mal da drauf.
Achso, ich habe noch nicht Run geklickt.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass wir Certbot verwenden können.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da Certbot überhaupt drankommt.
ich denke mal wir müssen irgendwas selbst sein das machen irgendwas mit
open ssl müssen wir machen ssl create self sein
beim vor 14 jahren stärker overflow
dass der brauner excellent interactive perfekt was das wollen wir haben aber
vorher müssen noch gucken weil wir sollen das mit demselben aussteller und
Also mit dem selben...
Mit dem selben...
Same Issuer and dem selben Subject.
Sollen wir das machen?
Okay, ist die Kiste jetzt da?
Oh, fuck, ich hab's zugemacht.
Ich kann Knub, nein.
Ich kann Knub.
Nein, ich will's nicht.
Nein, ich will's doch nicht.
Oh Gott.
cake wait wir haben gefällt heute so ran das hat mir die ip nicht angezeigt zum
ssh einloggen also müssen erstmal raus kriegen
welches subject das zertifikat hat
und dank und dank und dann können wir das hier von stack overflow machen
Subject ist dieses komplette Ding, ne?
Dieser komplette String, wo alles drin steht.
Company Name, ähm, äh, CN und was es nicht noch alles gibt.
Wie gesagt, Zertifikatssache ist wirklich Endgegner, ne?
Deswegen, ich mach das auch, wo es geht, einfach per ACME.
Ne, da steht nur da, wie du das rausbekommst
Da steht nur, wie du es testen kannst
Da steht nicht da, wie es geht
Okay, da sind wir
Zack
SSH
IDS.
Yes.
Excellent.
Okay, auf geht's.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Wir können das hier mal testen.
Ja, zack.
Der sagt, es ist nicht valid
before und es ist not valid after.
Also sprich, das Ganze ist
abgelaufen. Was haben wir denn hier für ein Datum?
Ist das richtig? 4. Juli.
Gibt es dazu eine gute Anleitung, Info?
Meinst du jetzt zu diesem Protokoll an sich oder zuletzt Encrypt?
Weil es gibt ja mehrere Anbieter mittlerweile, die das unterstützen.
Und theoretisch kannst du ja sogar intern das Ganze unterstützen.
Aber das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Also ich habe noch keine eigene CA oder wie auch immer es sein soll, aufgebaut, die das intern unterstützt, wo du dann mit Certbot dir intern Zertifikate holen kannst.
Automatischer Zertifikatsaustausch.
Ja, also da ist die Frage, wollt ihr, also könnt ihr gegen Let's Encrypt gehen oder braucht ihr was Internes, was das ausstellt?
Wenn ihr gegen Let's Encrypt geht, ist das Ganze easy.
Aber das geht ja nicht immer, weil Server zum Beispiel nicht ins Internet kommen oder keine DNS-Einträge machen dürfen oder sowas.
also je nach je nachdem wie das bei euch aufgebaut ist also wenn du einen server
hast der einträge in deinem dns server machen kann der für die domain
zuständig ist dann ist das easy as fuck
oder wenn du gar einen server hast eine public ip hat dann ist es noch noch noch
viel einfacher.
Du hast zwei
Möglichkeiten.
Du hast einmal halt diese ganze
Oldschool
DNS Challenge
heißt es.
Let's Encrypt DNS Challenge.
Das da brauchst du.
Genau, HTTP
Challenge.
Vault. Vault ist nice.
HashiCorp. Das habe ich sogar schon
verwendet.
Ja.
Also, HTTP-Challenge
verwendest du bei Let's Encrypt,
indem
du ein
eine Domain hast, die auf die
Public-IP von deinem Server zeigt
und das Server präsentiert dann einfach
so ein geheimes Secret hier drunter,
was Let's Encrypt abruft.
So. Das ist das
mit Abstand einfachste. Also, wenn
du einen public web server wenn uns generell wenn uns aber mit public ip
hast ist das easy da kannst du zum beispiel kaddi oder sowas als web server
nehmen das startest du und hast in drei sekunden zertifikat und das was machen
muss das nächste was auch für interne services funktioniert ist dns challenge
das funktioniert folgendermaßen du gehst an die letzten krypt api und
sagst, ich hätte gerne ein Zertifikat für diese Domain, dann sagt Let's Encrypt, okay,
dann hinterlege mal dieses geheime Secret auf deinem DNS, der für diese Domain zuständig
ist, als TXT-Rekord. Das machst du dann, Let's Encrypt ruft das ab, Let's Encrypt gibt dir
über Certbot zum Beispiel ein Zertifikat. Das benutze ich bei mir auch intern für interne
Zertifikate. Das ist super easy.
Ja.
So.
Was natürlich auch noch
eine Möglichkeit ist, wenn du es,
also wir reden jetzt von Sachen, die
einfach zu machen sind, ja.
Was du auch machen kannst ist,
du kannst
einen Proxy,
einen Reverse-Proxy
da vorstellen.
wenn du wirklich nur
also wenn du
wenn du SSL quasi weiter vorne
terminieren kannst, du kannst ein Reverse Proxy
da vorstellen, zum Beispiel in Nginx oder
irgendwas, der ist dann halt
der Endpunkt für alle deine
Domains und proxied
das im Endeffekt nur weiter auf deine Server dahinter
wenn du jetzt nicht wirklich
den
Traffic von und zum Server
selbst encrypten willst,
dann ist das auch eine gangbare
Variante.
Und ansonsten, wenn du das
wirklich alles intern handeln willst und
sowas, dann musst du dich tatsächlich mit sowas wie
mit Vault oder sowas
auseinandersetzen.
Das ist dann aber komplizierter.
Falls du einen Nginx Reverse-Proxy
verwenden willst, da gibt es zumindest für
Homelab
Verwendungszwecke,
was ganz praktisch ist, nämlich den hier.
Nginx Proxy Manager.
Da kriegst du ein schönes
Webinterface.
Da kriegst du ein schönes Webinterface.
Du kannst da quasi
deine ganzen...
Ich mach das mal kurz auf.
Du kannst quasi da
deine ganzen
Hosts, die du proxien willst, eintragen.
Ja, da sagst du,
ich will für diese Domain
macht dann quasi dein Webserver
TLS Terminierung und leitet es halt
halt
unencrypted weiter zu diesem Server dann.
Ach, da ist ein schönes Webinterface dabei.
Das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt was, das ist jetzt nicht die
krasse Premium Business Enterprise Lösung,
aber für kleine Installationen ist das sicherlich
nicht verkehrt.
Nutzt du
Tab-Switching per Scroll-Wheel?
Ne.
Ich weiß, dass das geht.
Ich glaube mit, was musst du drücken?
Control oder so?
Äh, keine Ahnung
Ich weiß gar nicht
Übrigens, wir müssen weitermachen
Unser Server wird gleich ausgeschaltet
Also wir haben einen Server, auf dem
Auf dem ein Webservice läuft
Es hat bei mir nicht funktioniert
So, wir haben hier einen Server
Der läuft auf Localhost
Und hat
Ein Zertifikat
das abgelaufen ist, weil das Zertifikat
ist nicht
nach dem hier
gültig und nicht
davor gültig.
Also das Zertifikat ist abgelaufen.
Das heißt,
wir müssen ein neues Zertifikat ausstellen.
Warte mal, es klopft.
Es klopft an der Tür.
So,
excellent, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ja genau, also wir haben ein Zertifikat,
was abgelaufen ist. Dann müssen wir doch jetzt mal
schauen, was hier Sache ist.
Dürfen wir root werden?
Dürfen wir. etc.
engine x
conf
Basic Settings
Das ist nix
Da müssen wir NNX Sites
Sites Enabled gucken
Default
Das ist die Webserver-Config dafür
Oder auch nicht
Ne
Ah hier
Hier
Das ist die Config
Also das ist das Zertifikat
Kriegt ihr auch immer Anfälle
wenn in Wim
standardmäßig Maus-Support eingeschaltet ist,
ich krieg da immer komplette Zustände.
Wer braucht...
Chat, ernsthaft.
Ich will euch nicht flamen.
Ich hab nix dagegen, wer das mag.
Gibt es jemanden, der den Maus-Support
in Wim benutzt und das gut findet?
Ich hab nämlich echt keine Ahnung,
wofür das gut sein soll.
Ja, es gibt extra Maus-Support.
Guck.
Wenn ich jetzt hier markiere,
dann macht der Visual Selection
sowas.
Da kannst du jetzt
Dateien in die Zwischenablage kopieren und sowas.
Wohlgemerkt in die lokale WIM-Zwischenablage.
Nicht jetzt hier bei mir lokal oder so.
Hoch.
Moment.
Chat.
Chat, welche schwarze Magie ist hier am Laufen?
Das Visual Selection per SSH auf einem WIM
in mein lokales Clipboard geht.
Chat, wie geht das?
Ne, ist gar nicht so.
Ist gar nicht so. Ist nicht so.
Hätte mich auch sehr gewundert.
Ist überhaupt nicht so. Das war das, was ich vorher markiert hatte.
Nicht das hier.
Das war Zufall.
Lul.
Weil das hätte mich jetzt echt,
das hätte mich jetzt komplett fertig gemacht.
Also, Zertifikat.
Dazu sagen wir jetzt erstmal
Set Maus gleich nix.
Also das hier ist das Zertifikat.
Das ist der Key.
Das ist der Private Key.
Das ist das Zertifikat.
Und das müssen wir jetzt neu ausstellen.
Damit wir ein neues gültiges Zertifikat bekommen.
Dann nehmen wir doch mal das, was wir hier von Stack Overflow haben.
Und zwar das da.
Bam.
So, das nennen wir
Nginx-Sort, Nginx-Key
Okay, ich mach das mal hier im Rootverzeichnis
Ist ja egal
Also wir wollen einmal
Ups
Wir wollen einmal
Nginx-Key
und
nginx.cert
und jetzt soll er mich mal abfragen, was ich habe.
Achso, Moment, Moment.
Wir sollen das Zertifikat ja generieren
für
Oh, ich habe zu lange rumgeschwätzt.
Wir haben nur noch 8 Minuten Zeit.
Wir sollen das Zertifikat ja generieren
für den Issuer
vom selben Issuer
Ne
Okay, okay
Dann gucken wir doch mal nach
Was das eigentlich für ein
Subject und so Zeug hat
Hä
So.
Dann machen wir das mal weg.
End-Certificate.
Bam.
Cyber-Chef.
Beste für sowas.
Kennt ihr das?
Cyber-Chef.
So.
Also.
CN.
Ja, ich weiß.
Es geht auch überhaupt um SSL.
Also.
Also, CN Localhost, OAKME.
Okay, das sollten wir doch hinkriegen.
Ja, das, das, das funzt auch.
Aber ich finde trotzdem das hier, ich benutze das gern.
Weiß auch nicht.
Obwohl ich bin normalerweise, wisst ihr ja, bin ich CLI-Fan, kein GUI-Klicker.
Aber...
Gut, also dann machen wir das doch mal.
Wo haben wir das OpenSSL-Command?
Also das brauchen wir.
Generating Key.
Passphrase. Keine.
What?
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
MonkaS, Alter.
Okay.
Wir machen hier
Magic Command.
Okay.
Alles geht.
Okay, wenn man es so macht, ist alles okay.
Na dann.
Dann wollen wir hier Engine X.
Engine X Key.
Also wie gesagt, Zertifikatszentren sind immer massive Paints, Cembala.
Okay.
Also, was wollen wir jetzt haben?
Wir wollen...
Kann man sich das nicht ordentlich ausgeben lassen hiermit?
Dass man sagen kann...
Open SSL Print Subject Line so komplett, dass ich das einfach copy-pasten kann.
Ne, ne, das will ich nicht. Ich will die komplette Subject.
Ja, das kenne ich auch.
Naja.
Gut, dann tippen wir. Das ist auch wurscht.
Aber wir können uns das hier gerade mal
Subject rauskreppen.
Und dann führen wir das hier aus.
Also, was brauchen wir?
Wir brauchen...
Was ist das eigentlich schon wieder für eine abartige Syntax, Mann?
Also wir brauchen
O
ACME
OU
IT Department
Hoffentlich geht das so
L
CN
Localhost wahrscheinlich
localhost
so und was ist das denn
ok was haben wir noch vergessen
l
gleich
links
st
gleich
schweiz
hab ich was vergessen
weiß nicht
Name is expected to be informed.
What?
Oh Gott, das ist ja immer so...
Ah, hat der vielleicht Probleme, dass da ein Leerzeichen drin ist?
Oh, please.
Zertifikatsgenerierung.
Was hat er denn?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
This is not in the format.
Okay.
Was habe ich denn falsch gemacht?
Was ist denn jetzt falsch hier dran schon wieder?
WTF?
Chat, seht ihr, was ich falsch gemacht habe?
Ach, musste am Ende,
musste am Ende vielleicht...
Da muss am Anfang ein Slash.
Obviously, Leute.
Natürlich muss da am Anfang ein Slash.
Also, Chat, wenn das jetzt nicht klar ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Logisch.
Okay.
Okay, ich kopiere mir das mal, falls mir gleich die Session wegfliegt.
Oh, habe ich mich verguckt?
Habe ich falsch? Habe ich falsch?
ST ist... Achso, du hast recht.
ST ist auch gleich das.
und C ist gleich
CH.
Okay.
So, und wo muss das Zertifikat jetzt hin?
Das muss nach
ETC Engine X CRT.
CP Engine X
Cert, kopiert nach
ETC Engine X Cert.
Engine X
E
kopiert nach Engine X Key.
System CTL
Restart
Nginx. Bam. Und jetzt
Open SSL.
Ja, das ist schön und gut.
Was hat der hier vorhin gemacht?
Oh fuck, 40 Sekunden.
OMG.
Okay, passt.
Passt, Leute. Wir sind genau
pünktlich.
Check my solution.
Jawoll. 40 Sekunden vor Schluss.
Habe wir nochmal geschafft, Leute.
Äh.
Ja, dann shutte mal den Server down.
Ich habe am Anfang zu viel über Let's Encrypt gelabert.
ok next
also description
die pl ich habe so irgendwo vor
also was ist das nächste szenario was wir haben auf diesem rechner läuft ein
nx web server und sagen das hat mir doch gerade okay das ist im ddienst lockt cleaner service soll
manuell ausgeführt werden nicht über einen time oder grand job und protokoll dateien löschen die
älter als sieben tage sind und sich im verzeichnis war lockt app befinden der dienst wird erfolgreich
ausgeführt, es werden jedoch keine Protokolle
gelöscht. Korrigieren
Sie den Dienst und oder das
Skript, sodass Old Data
Log älter als
7 Tage gelöscht wird. Recent
Data Log jedoch erhalten bleibt.
Falls Sie beim Debuggen versehentlich die falschen
Dateien löschen, führen Sie Reset Logs aus,
um sie wiederherzustellen. Okay,
auf geht's. Let's
go. Run.
Ich hätte, ich futter mal mein Toastbowl nebenbei.
und mache mal
einen kleinen Sellout.
Chat, wenn ihr gerade euch überlegt,
vielleicht ein NAS zu kaufen
oder
Festplatten
für Storage,
dann könnt ihr jetzt auf meinen Link hier gehen,
Ausrufezeichen Seagate, Ausrufezeichen
Ukraine im Chat oder hier über die
Kanalbeschreibung kriegt ihr einen Link.
Der führt auf einen eigenen
Wobblors Alternate Shop.
Und ich wurde dazu angehalten,
euch nochmal zu sagen,
die Preise gelten nur
exklusiv über meinen Link.
Sonst ist es teurer.
Und da findet ihr beispielsweise 8TB
Platten für 339 Euro.
Mittlerweile ist
es doch überall teurer.
Ein paar Euro günstiger ist immer gut.
oder ihr könnt euch auch gleich das Ganze mit einem Ugreen NAS als Bundle kaufen.
Ich persönlich, mir persönlich, ich finde dieses NAS hier mega nice,
weil das ein 4-Kern-Low-Power-Interhalt-CPU ist mit, das hier stimmt nicht, 2,5 Gigabit-Netzwerk.
Die CPU hat Quick Sync und ISNI, was heißt, ihr könnt, es hat Crypto Extensions
und ihr könnt da theoretisch mit auch das ein oder andere Video transcoden.
Also, nice surprise.
Und weiter jetzt hier, Zetke.
Yes!
ok auf geht's der lok cleaner service es lag gerade brutal alles weg krass
Also der Lock Cleaner Service ist am Start
Dann gucken wir doch mal
Was in diesem Lock Cleaner Service so drin steht
Bin Bash
Erstmal Maus unterstützen
Type One Shot
Ganz ehrlich System D Syntax
Keine Ahnung aber
Das Work Directory
ist slash root.
Das klingt jetzt vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll, aber wir gucken
wir gucken mal kurz
in diesen
Wir gucken mal in das Skript rein.
Was da drin steht.
Also.
Welche Linux-Distribution?
Das hier ist
CacheOS. Also hier, das da.
Das ist CacheOS.
CacheOS mit KDE.
Also was macht denn hier
das LogCleaner-Skript?
LogDir war LogApp, das ist richtig.
7 Tage.
7 Tage ist glaube ich
hier auch richtig.
Find.
MarksDepth
1.
Das ist okay.
Das will ja auch alles direkt nur unterhalb
löschen.
Type F
M
Time 7
Das ist Modified
Time. Vielleicht brauchen wir auch
Creation Time. Boah, das kann ich mir
immer nicht merken.
Print Delete. Sternchen.
Punkt Lock. Macht Sternchen.
Lock an sich Sinn? Ja.
Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen,
das hier ist gar nicht so verkehrt,
oder? Schauen wir mal.
Findet aber nichts.
Achso.
Ach, plötzlich bin ich noch nicht richtig. Verzeihung.
Warlock. Das ist übrigens auch immer
ein Tipp, den ich geben kann, wenn man so Dinge
debuggt. Versuchen das möglichst
aufs Kleinste zu reduzieren.
Also sich einfach mal die Zeile hier raus
kopieren und von Hand ausführen, halt ohne Print.
Okay. Der findet
witzigerweise
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
Der findet nur Recent Log
Und der findet nichts
All Log ist vom 15.
15.
März
Und das andere ist vom 4.
Also von heute
So
Dann ist das Feind irgendwie verkehrt.
Das sollte...
M-Time. Boah, wie ist da die richtige
Syntax für?
Ist das plus 7 Tage?
Genau.
So, Old Data.
Das ist übrigens
falsch geschrieben. Es ist genau umgedreht.
Also, das Feind ist schon mal verkehrt gewesen.
Dann machen wir hier mal ein Plus draus.
Und jetzt führen wir mal den Service aus.
Wobei halt die Frage ist...
Ne, Lockdeer?
Guck mal, das stimmt auch nicht.
Hier muss Dollar Lockdeer hin.
Noch.
Sonst guckt der im falschen Verzeichnis.
Na?
Okay. System CTL.
Start. Lock.
Cleaner.
Wie war es das jetzt schon?
Also dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Easy.
Das war easy, oder?
Da war das mit den Zertifikaten aber deutlich schwieriger.
Massive Eats.
Easy.
Ja.
Aber Zertifikatskram ist immer eklig.
Immer.
Haben wir geschafft?
Easy.
Port outed.
Okay, mal kurz gucken, was wir jetzt machen sollen.
Beschreibung.
Das Sicherheitsteam hat gängige Tools
zur Netzwerkaufklärung von diesem Host
entfernt.
Oh, dummes Sicherheitsteam, ey.
Was machen die auch immer für einen Scheiß?
Ihre Aufgabe ist es, festzustellen,
welche TCP-Ports
auf dem Local Host
Verbindung akzeptieren.
Dann machen wir einfach Netcat oder irgendwie sowas
Die zu prüfenden Ports sind in der Datei
Home Admin Ports
To scan
Aufgeführt
Oh ich hab ne Idee wir machen jetzt was ganz abgedrehtes
Da
Wir machen jetzt was ganz abgedrehtes
Wir machen jetzt Bash
Mit Bash geht das doch auch
Es gibt doch so ein Trick
Wie man mit Bash TCP Verbindung aufmachen kann
schreiben sie ihre ergebnisse in die datei home admin port audit txt wobei pro port eine zeile
zu erstellen ist sortiert nach portnummer aufsteigen verwenden sie dabei folgendes format
Port Status.
Okay.
Na dann.
Run.
Bäm.
Bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Wir haben kein Netstat.
Dieses Linux-Kommando traue ich mich immer nicht,
on stream auszusprechen, Leute.
Zzz, nenne ich es jetzt einfach mal.
Also Zzz
ist nicht drauf.
Netstat ist nicht drauf.
Nmap nicht drauf.
NC ist nicht drauf.
Wahrscheinlich ist Netcat auch nicht drauf.
Tenor ist nicht drauf.
Curl ist nicht drauf.
LS Office ist nicht drauf und TCP-Dump ist nicht drauf.
Okay.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Es gibt nämlich die Möglichkeit, hier,
Bash Open TCP.
Es gibt so ne ganz abgedrehte
Geschichte in Bash.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Nicht mit Netcat.
Hier.
Das hier.
Das hier meine ich.
Das ist super abgedrehtes Zeug
Okay, zack
Netcat ist noch nicht drauf
Sonntagmorgen bin ich auch wieder am Start
Also was gibt es jetzt?
Port Audit?
Ports to Scan haben wir hier
Okay, das hält sich ja nun mal
wirklich sehr in Grenzen, was davon offen ist
Ob SSH offen ist, kann ich ja
einfach schon ausprobieren, indem ich so mache
Also SSH ist offen, ja
Also Telnet haben wir
Äh
sicher, dass wir...
Äh, Chat?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Absicht ist, dass Telnet
da drauf verfügbar ist.
Netznet ist...
Der hat vergessen, Telnet zu uninstallen.
Okay, wir tun mal so, als ist Telnet nicht drauf.
Okay?
Wir ignorieren das.
Okay, der andere...
Der hat Telnet nicht uninstalled.
Okay, das ist natürlich sehr unpraktisch.
Damit könnte man das halt easy austricksen.
Also, machen wir mal hier.
Hier sind die, hier sind die, hier sind die, die Ports.
Ports to scan.
Do, Echo, Dollar, E, dann Bam, so.
Eder, Port.
Jetzt brauchen wir das hier von Steg Overflow.
diese Magic-Geschichte hier.
Das da.
Das steht doch nicht verfügbar.
Ja, aber es ist verfügbar.
Guck mal.
Das ist halt drauf.
Ich glaube, der hat es vergessen.
Der hat es vergessen zu eininstallen.
Wie funzt das jetzt?
Okay, Local Host.
Connection Refuse.
Interesting hier.
Das ist halt geil, dass es mit Bash geht, oder?
Sag doch mal. Das ist doch wirklich Pogu.
Also, wir machen jetzt eine Schleife.
Vor I in.
So.
Dann sagen wir dem,
dieses hässliche Ding hier wollen wir ausführen.
Und zwar, ich quote das mal so, dass ich da was einsetzen kann.
Und zwar auf Dollar-I. Das ist der Port.
Vielleicht nennen wir es nicht I, sondern Port.
Ich weiß, das ist hier Linux-Diwa. Aber das ist geil, dass das funktioniert.
Dollar-Port. Okay.
Ich würde sagen, alle Ports sind offen bis 4.4.4.9.9.
Aber wir können das ja noch besser machen.
Wir können jetzt sagen...
Wenn...
Wir sollen jetzt eine Datei...
Was sollen wir jetzt nochmal für eine Datei erstellen?
So eine Datei soll dann am Ende rauskommen.
Also es soll dann raus
Da steht 22 open
Closed oder so
Okay, ganz ehrlich Leute
Das ist so gering, das lohnt sich nicht zu skripten
Es sind
Es sind im Endeffekt
Wir machen es jetzt nochmal so
Seien es und und und
Ähm, Echo, Dollar, Port, Open
So
Also im Endeffekt sind
Oder wir machen es andersrum.
Oder, oder.
Port closed.
Also, 444 und 999 sind closed.
Der Rest ist eats.
Gehen wir nämlich einfach hier hin.
4444.
Hier.
4444 ist closed.
999 ist closed.
Und der Rest ist open.
Eats.
Check my solution.
Bam.
Easy clap, Leute.
Easy.
Aber okay, das ist ja auch eine easy Aufgabe.
Die darf auch easy sein.
Wir haben noch ein paar easy Aufgaben
Also ganz ehrlich
Die OpenSSL-Aufgabe
Was sagt ihr, Chat?
Diese OpenSSL-Aufgabe
Oder generell diese Zertifikatsaufgabe
Die wir hier eben hatten
Das da
Die hätten sie doch fast schon unter Medium packen können, oder?
Ist das ein Game?
Das ist sowas ähnliches
Du hast hier eine Liste mit kaputten Linux-Servern.
Du kriegst, also ich kann dir das mal zeigen, wenn du das noch nicht gesehen hast.
Guck mal.
Du kriegst hier eine Aufgabe gestellt, was mit dem Server kaputt ist.
Wenn du die Aufgabe startest, hast du eine gewisse...
Ja, genau, genau.
CTF-mäßig.
Dann hast du so und so viel Zeit.
Und du kriegst dann quasi eine echte Linux-VM.
Also das ist keine Sandbox oder irgendwie simulierte Umgebung.
Du kriegst eine echte Linux-VM.
Ich glaube bei AWS läuft das.
die halt dann mit Ansible kaputt
professioniert wird, auf denen ihrer Seite
und du musst es fixen.
Open SSL ist kryptisch, ja.
Hat jemand einen guten
Linux-Kurs?
Bin ich so fit in Linux und das Unternehmen
würde mir einen Kurs besorgen?
Kurs habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir sagen, was aus meiner Sicht
am besten hilft.
Also Kurs weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht weiß der Chat das.
Aber was aus meiner Sicht am besten hilft ist, wenn du selbst Linux verwendest.
Ich meine damit es nicht auf irgendeinem Server oder so, sondern wirklich täglich Linux verwendest.
Was? Labex? Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Aber wenn der Chat das sagt.
Du kannst dir entweder Linux in einer VM installieren.
So habe ich das by the way eine ganze Weile gemacht.
Also ich habe hier einfach Linux hier bei einem VM oder Workstation.
Vm oder Workstation kostet mittlerweile übrigens nichts mehr.
Hier hatte ich den Linux-VM und habe dann ganz normal einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop mit der Linux-VM gearbeitet im Fullscreen.
Das hier ist überhaupt kein Ding. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Oder aber, was ich persönlich noch einen Ticken nicer finde, ist aber die Frage, ob das in deinen Workflow reinpasst.
Guck, hier habe ich im Endeffekt meinen Linux-VM.
Da habe ich auch alles mögliche, was ich gebraucht habe drauf
Und ich arbeite mehr in der Linux-Farm als unter Windows selbst
Und das ist auch schnell genug
Ich meine, das war auch eine fette VM hier mit 8 CPU-Kernen und 24 GB RAM
Zumindest, VM ist eine gute Möglichkeit
Und du benutzt dann diese VM ganz normal für deine tägliche Arbeit, was du so machst
Wenn du was programmieren musst, machst du das unter Linux
Also es sei denn, es ist Windows-Only-Software, ja
Wenn du irgendwelche Server zusammen klickst bei irgendeinem Clown, dann mach das unter Linux.
Benutz das einfach täglich und du wirst automatisch saumäßig viel lernen.
Oder aber, du kaufst dir einen Mini-PC.
Ich hab hier zum Beispiel einen, der ist aber schon ein bisschen älter, da gibt es mittlerweile sicherlich neuere Kisten.
Ich hab mir so einen kleinen Mini-PC gekauft, wie gesagt, 2023, schon ein bisschen älter.
Darauf Linux installiert.
Und das ist das...
Achso, das backt ja immer ein bisschen rum hier.
Machen wir das wieder aus.
So soll ich mehr RAM verbrauchen, als irgendwie notwendig.
Und den Linux-PC ist den, den du hier siehst.
Das ist der Mini-PC.
Guck hier mit Mobile 780M und einem 8-Kern.
Das ist ein 8-Kern-CPU, 16 Uhr mit Hyper-Threading.
Und dann hast du den Linux auf dem Mini-PC.
Und den verwende ich quasi fast ausschließlich hier.
Kaum Windows, wenn wir streamen.
Nook, klar.
Easy.
Nook ist Intel. Intel ist auch gut unter Linux.
Jaja.
Du musst halt irgendein Setup finden,
was dich nicht nervt.
Sodass du es halt auch wirklich täglich verwendest.
Deswegen empfehle ich auch kein Dual Boot.
Dual Boot ist immer die Hürde zu groß.
Nee, nee, Windows deinstallieren würde ich nicht.
Was machst du, wenn du wirklich mal was brauchst,
wo du nur weißt, wie es unter Windows geht?
Oder was, was nur unter Windows geht?
Nee, das würde ich nicht machen.
Ich würde einfach Windows für das nehmen, wofür es, fällt mir schwer zu sagen, ich will nicht sagen gut ist, aber für das es noch besser geeignet ist in manchen Bereichen als Linux.
Ja, also Gaming geht zwar mittlerweile auch wunderbar unter Linux oder deutlich, also viel, viel, viel, viel, viel besser wie noch vor ein paar Jahren.
Alles funktioniert nicht.
Also spätestens wenn du Spiele mit Anti-Cheat spielen willst, geht das nicht.
vielleicht auch irgendwelche Musik
und Video und Grafikbearbeitung.
Wobei es mit DaVinci Resolve
ein gutes Cross-Plattform-Videoschnittprogramm gibt.
Und für Musik mittlerweile wohl das auch ganz gut.
Aber da kenne ich mich nicht, wie das unter Linux gehen soll.
Aber so Mini-PC.
Und wenn du wirklich täglich damit arbeitest mit deinem Linux,
dann lernst du da auch jede Menge,
weil du dich halt täglich mit auseinandersetzen musst.
Da lernst du dann halt auch so Krams hier auf der Kommandozeilen-Handling, ja?
Schon up to date. Oh Mist, ich muss updaten. Du hast recht.
Und dann rebooten. Das Problem ist, wir haben hier schon...
Achso, wir haben noch gar nicht gestartet.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht rebooten, dann muss ich mich neu einloggen.
Ne, ich hab noch nicht geupdatet, hab ich heute nicht dran gedacht.
Wie kommst du drauf?
Du wolltest wissen, ob ich meinem Reboot-Drang schon nachgegangen bin?
Warum rebooten? Weil garantiert Kernel-Update fällig ist.
Okay, dann machen wir das mal. Also, welches Szenario haben wir denn hier jetzt zu bieten?
Problem ist, haben wir ein Windows-PC als Hauptsystem und halt den Nook.
aber müsste ja alles umklemmen und mit dem Home Office muss ich auch alles umstecken.
Voll pöt, könntest einen KVM Switch holen?
Einer von euch bin voll der Kacken, du bist erst die Ausbildung, schaffst ein Werk, aber
hast keine Ahnung.
Also, also, okay.
Ease of use, Setup, Vm.
Lad dir Vm in der Workstation runter und mach das so wie ich hier.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Du kannst hier Linux Mint installieren, du kannst dir, ähm, na gut.
später irgendwann installiert er den barge linux in städte ruhig linux mit die lux mint hat auch
noch x das läuft ja vor allem am besten das ganze war nach dem vm auf den zweiten windows desktop
linux im fullscreen und gutes ich kann dir bei der gelegenheit aber gerade mal zeigen wie ich
das hier mache weil bei mir ist das so du siehst ja hier ich habe hier windows und hier linux er
Jetzt natürlich die große Preisfrage, wie funktioniert denn das?
Und das ist ein bisschen trickreich, wie das funktioniert.
Hat das jetzt eigentlich diesen Dark-Modus ausgeschaltet?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen trickreich, wie das funktioniert.
Ich zeige es dir aber mal, vielleicht ist das ein Setup, was dich an sich auch interessiert.
Du kannst auch Remote Desktop auf den Linux, auf den NUC machen, das funktioniert auch.
Bei mir ist das ein bisschen abgedrehter gelöst und zwar, ich zeige dir das mal, guck mal.
erster desktop windows zweiter desktop unter windows ist eigentlich ein obs
ein obs mit einer capture card drin und zwar ich habe hier eine elgato eine pci
elgato capture card und mein mini pc steckt eigentlich in der capture card
drin und die capture card ist hier ein obs
So, und das ist eigentlich nur ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Verstehste?
So, jetzt haben wir die nächste Frage, Chat.
Denn die nächste Frage, die sich einem jetzt da zwangsläufig stellt, ist,
wie kriege ich denn jetzt meine Maus und Tastatur, ohne umzustecken, von Windows...
von Windows an Linux dran?
Und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ihr seht, wenn ich einfach nur den Desktop switche unter Windows,
Dann ist hier die Maus noch die Windows-Maus.
Hier bewegt sich nichts.
Und zwar funktioniert das Ganze folgendermaßen.
Ich habe hier ein Programm, das nennt sich Deskflow.
Deskflow ist ein Tool, da kann man Maus und Tastatur übers Netzwerk sharen.
Und was dann passiert ist, wenn ich das hier mache.
Guck mal hier, Deskflow.
Ich muss das hier mal groß machen.
Deskflow.
Ihr seht, guck, der switcht.
Also
Ich hab dem gesagt
Mini PC steht
Steht neben Desktop PC
Und mit Desktop kannst du Maus und Tastatur sharen
So und damit ich das easy umschalten kann
Mit Desktop PC
Das ist jetzt hier OBS Linux im Hintergrund mit Windows Overlay
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen durcheinander
So damit das ordentlich funktioniert
Habe ich in meiner Logitech
In meiner Logitech Tastatur Software
Habe ich noch ein Makro hinterlegt
Und zwar
Ein Makro, ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal eins davon
Äh
Ein Makro
Nämlich
Switchen, ich muss umgedreht zeigen
Switchen auf die Linux Desktop
Ich drücke
Linke Windows Taste
Und
Control
und nach rechts.
So, wenn ich das jetzt mal von Hand mache,
dann lande ich auf dem zweiten Desktop,
aber noch mit Windows, okay?
Ist ja auch ein Windows Desktop.
Und dann drücke ich Alt-Ä.
Alt-Ä ist, jetzt bin ich hier drauf mit Windows,
Alt-Ä ist ein Shortcut in Deskflow,
der wiederum hinterlegt hat,
Deskflow hat wiederum hinterlegt,
Ich bin gar nicht sicher, wo man das sieht
Configure Server
Shortcuts, Hotkeys
Genau, hier
Switch, Alt-Ä und Alt-Ö
Ist Desktop-Switchen in Deskflow
So, und was
Jetzt meine Shortcuts machen, ist eigentlich
Nur ganz schnell zu drücken
Windows Desktop, Alt-Ä
Und dann bin ich wieder auf Linux
Und wenn ich zurück switchen will, drückt der Alt-Ö
Switch Deskflow zurück
Und dann Ctrl Alt linke Maustaste
So nice oder
Das ist so
Warum ist das cursed
Das ist richtig nice
So habe ich alles auf dem gleichen Bildschirm
Und es hat kein lag
Die PCI Capture Karte ist super schnell
Also ich würde jetzt da keine Competitive Shooter drauf spielen
Unter Linux ja
Aber für solche Sachen hier ist das komplett ausreichend
Wie ich auf die Idee gekommen bin?
Naja, weil ich eben auf dem gleichen Monitor ohne Umstöpseln Linux und Windows haben will.
Ich habe das als Ablösung geplant für meine VM, weil mit der war das einfacher.
Ja.
Also das würde ich nicht machen.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, ohne Scheiß, installiere dir VM bei Workstation, installiere dir Linux Mint,
pack dir VM bei Workstation im Fullscreen auf den zweiten Desktop und benutze das einfach.
Dann lernst du viel.
Alternativ kannst du dann auch drüber nachdenken, ob du dir nicht daheim ein bisschen was zum Testen hinstellst
Früher hätte ich gesagt, ein Raspberry Pi, die Dinger sind jetzt mittlerweile schweineteuer
Ja, du kannst auch deinen NUC, kannst du auch Debian drauf installieren und darauf mal so ein paar lokale Services laufen lassen
Aber ich würde mir lieber einen Desktop holen, den täglich verwenden und dann noch eine extra kleine Kiste vielleicht von Ebay
mit Debian drauf und da ein bisschen Server-Kram ausprobieren.
Aber das Beste, ohne Scheiß, die beste Art, Linux zu lernen, meiner Meinung nach,
ich weiß, Chat könnt mir ja sagen, wie ihr das seht,
ist kein Linux-Kurs zu machen, sondern täglich Linux zu verwenden
und sich halt mit den Problemen, die da so aufploppen, auseinanderzusetzen.
Da lernst du viel schneller und effektiver, als irgendeinen abstrakten Kurs machen.
Aber warum nicht Windows virtualisieren statt Linux?
Wie soll ich denn unter Windows gescheit spielen, wenn ich es unter Linux virtualisiere?
Jetzt komme ich mit GPU-Paththrough.
Dann hast du ja noch ganz andere Probleme.
GPU-Paththrough, da brauchst du einen eigenen Monitor, den du an die Grafikkarte anschließt.
Dann hast du das gleiche Problem wie ich hier mit hin und her schalten.
Dann musst du so Sachen wie Looking Glass verwenden.
Das ist nix.
Das Setup, was ich hier habe, ist das Beste.
Ich habe volle Performance unter Windows für Games.
und ich habe volle Performance unter Linux
und alles, was ich brauche, hier drüber.
Einfach auch Linux-Gaming.
Ja, spiel mal beispielsweise Overwatch
oder irgendwelche Spiele mit Anti-Cheat.
Es sei denn, die Supporten.
Es gibt ja immer mehr, die supporten,
aber viele supporten es nicht.
So, so sieht es aus.
Gut, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben eigentlich?
Hier, dieses Szenario haben wir jetzt.
Fehler bei der FTP-Katalog-Synchronisierung.
Schwierigkeitsgrad einfach. Typ beheben. Text FTP, ja, sehr schön.
Also Beschreibung. Die Warehouse-API auf diesem Haus sollte unter
127001.9178 mit einem Textkörper antworten.
Wie ist das übersetzt?
Mit einem Textkörper antworten, der okay enthält.
Wie mache ich das mit dem Homeoffice?
Weil ein Laptop und ein PC
stirbst du alles um und dock.
Aber ist ja blöd. Eigentlich hilft da nur KVM.
Wie gesagt, wenn du es nicht so abartig
machen willst wie ich,
KVM. KVM ist auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit.
Gibt es auch relativ günstige.
Oder, wie gesagt,
du kannst doch erstmal mit
KVM auf deiner Linus-Kiste probieren.
Achso, du musst so und so umstöpseln, weil Laptop
und PC. Achso.
Ja, KVM-Switch ist nicht
verkehrt.
So.
Genau.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich...
Ah, wir haben zum Glück noch nicht auf Start gedrückt.
Das ist gut.
Genau, so sieht's aus.
Run!
Und, well, was war jetzt die Aufgabe?
Nochmal, nochmal kurz weiterlesen.
Okay, also...
Okay.
Ich muss das mal auf Englisch lesen.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich greife über HTTP auf die API zu.
Und die API antwortet mit OK.
So, und dieses File, woraus das erkennt, dass es OK ist,
wird intern über ein FTP...
Oh Gott, nee.
Please.
Nein.
Keine FTP-Sachen.
Hör mal auf.
Das mache ich nicht.
Das ignoriere ich, die Aufgabe.
alter fdp ok das job at home admin edinburghs zündsh ist failing
api never comes up healthy fix das so die katalog ist download and api works
again okay naja vielleicht vielleicht haben wir mit fdp gar nicht so viel zu tun
da sind wir also wir checken ist jetzt erst mal was hier passiert
curl. Bam.
Failed. Lauscht.
Okay.
Moment.
Der lauscht gar nicht. Oder was?
Was soll denn da laufen überhaupt?
Ein NGX oder was?
Oder was läuft denn da?
Mal gucken.
Schauen wir uns gleich mal an.
existiert nicht.
Also, schauen wir uns mal hier das Sync an.
Set Maus gleich.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Okay, das Ding kackt ab. Wir führen es jetzt einfach mal aus.
Okay? Das Ding, also das hier oben
heißt im Endeffekt, beim ersten
Fehler soll das Bash-Skript
abkacken. Bam.
Ups. Ups. Äh.
Wir führen das jetzt einfach mal aus. Zack.
Okay. Also.
Er connectet sich. Passwort re-quired.
Login successful.
Passive off.
Local.
Remote. Catalog.
Port. R. E. Not allowed.
Use passive.
Can't bind for date. Okay, wir müssen
passives PDF verwenden anstatt
active PDF.
PDF?
FDP. Wie komme ich auf PDF?
Egal. Legacy. Legacy-Technologie
alles sowie verwendet man ein passives pdf was weil leute jetzt legit ehrlich
gemeinte frage wann habt ihr das letzte mal ein ftp transfer gemacht ich glaube
das ist bei mir ohne scheiß 15 jahre her
User bin Passive. Muss man hier Passive on schreiben?
Passive on vielleicht einfach und dann geht's?
Eats!
Aber kernel lässt sich der Server immer noch nicht.
Was sollte denn hier? Steht hier, was jetzt eigentlich lauschen sollte?
Was sollte denn hier eigentlich auf 9178 lauschen?
Guck mal mal.
Wir sind jetzt...
Wir waren jetzt Blutforce-mäßig.
Wir gucken...
Oh, fuck.
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Äh.
Kann das sein, dass es überhaupt keinen Webserver gibt oder so?
Okay.
scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Also
haben die hier überhaupt
einen Webserver?
Mit was soll das hier denn überhaupt laufen?
Der Sync
funktioniert.
Aber ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das für ein Webserver
Habe ich hier Root?
ETC? Was haben wir denn hier für einen Web-Server?
Steht das da?
Steht da was von Service?
Ah!
Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Hätten wir mal richtig lesen sollen.
Failed!
Okay, Restart.
Bam!
Status.
Zack!
Cool.
Zack. Kunst.
Easy.
Geschafft, Leute.
Okay.
Hätte ich es mal richtig gelesen,
dann wäre das wahrscheinlich
deutlich simpler gewesen,
anstatt es nach irgendeinem Webserver zu suchen.
Okay.
Dann haben wir das geschafft. Easy.
Next.
Jetzt haben wir noch eine, ne zwei haben wir noch.
Bolognese
habe ich heute Mittag.
Mittag gab es Spaghetti Bolognese
mit veganem
Hackfleisch.
Vor einem Jahr hätte ich noch gesagt,
Alter hör mal bloß auf.
Aber ich muss sagen, es gibt viele vegane Sachen,
die echt gar nicht schlecht schmecken.
Ich bin kein Veganer, bin auch kein Vegetarier,
Aber ich versuche ein bisschen weniger Fleisch zu essen, was ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so sehr was mit Tierwohl zu tun hat, sondern weil zu viel Fleisch essen ungesund ist.
Hat die Bolognese anders geschmeckt? Ein bisschen, ein bisschen.
Aber nachdem bei Bolognese das meiste eh Tomatensauce und Gewürze sind, hat man das kaum gemerkt, dass es hat eigentlich bei Wörtherwieder genauso geschmeckt.
also hat so gut was hat wirklich eigentlich genauso geschmeckt okay hier
operations handelt classic classic ein classic rws aws aws elastik laut
Balancer.
Ich muss mich als AWS-Noob outen,
Leute.
Classic
AWS. Ja.
Ich muss mich als AWS-Noob outen.
Bei meinem alten Job war es
fast ausschließlich Azure.
Bei meinem neuen Job ist es ein kleines bisschen
Azure und hauptsächlich Google Cloud.
Ich habe von AWS
nicht wirklich viel Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, das müssen wir
auch gar nicht hierfür.
Operations handed you a classic
AWS Elastic Load Balancer
Access Log Ad. Achso.
Each line is one request.
Fields are space separated.
Fields are space
separated.
The quoted
HTTP request starts at
Field 12, so the numeric
fields before it are fixed
with columns. Okay.
Feld 8 ist der ELB-Status.
9 ist Backend-Status.
Count how many log lines
Have a backend-Status-Code
in der 500er-Range.
Ach so.
Okay, ich muss überhaupt nichts mit Elastik zu tun haben.
Wir müssen im Endeffekt ein bisschen
Cut und Crep machen, vermutlich.
Easy, das kriegen wir hin.
Da bin ich zuversichtlich.
Klassiker
Oh sellout modus chat
Ihr habt ja gerade das banner gesehen was eingeblendet wurde ihr könnt jetzt ausrufezeichen ukraine oder ausrufezeichen seagate im chat machen
kommt ihr auf den eigens für mich generierten alternate link beziehungsweise den alternate wobblers shop
oder ihr könnt auch im kanal banner gucken
ist auch so ein bild was sie anklicken könnt und die preise die ihr da seht sind exklusive wobblers preise die gibt es nur über den link
Könnt ihr günstig Ukraine-Nasses kaufen und festplatten.
Was ja gerade in der heutigen Zeit nicht verkehrt ist.
Okay, let's go.
Wir kopieren uns einfach nur noch das da.
Dann ist das deutlich einfacher.
Yes.
Okay, also wir haben eine Datei.
Die Home Admin ELB Log.
Also im Prinzip einfach nur ELB Log.
Ja.
Also, die sollen wir...
Wir sollen uns was raussuchen.
Fields are space separated.
Äh, Quote, ne Moment, Moment.
Ist das wirklich nur, ja doch, die Fields sind wirklich space,
nur hier, nur hier sind Spaces, okay.
Space separated.
HTTP request is field 12.
8 ist der ELB-Status-Code
und 49 ist Backend-Status-Code.
Count how many
Loglines have a backend status
Code
Okay, also im Prinzip, im Prinzip Feld 8
Im Prinzip kann man sich
Den restlichen Kram speichern, wir brauchen im Prinzip
Cut, delimiter
Space, field 8
So, oder
Jetzt machen wir einfach mal
Sort, easy
Wir machen Sort Numeric
Ich, ich, ich
Ich cheese, ich cheese das jetzt einfach mal
Ein bisschen, okay
Sortnumeric
Blub.txt
Wim, Blub.txt
Brrrr
Zack
Blub.txt
WC-L
Okay, wo soll die Solution reingeschrieben werden da?
Bam
Ups
Äh, what the fuck
Check my solution
Bam, korrekt
Easy clap
Chat, konntet ihr mir folgen
Oder soll ich das nochmal machen und erklären dabei
Ich hab keine Schmerzen mit
Ich kann das gerne nochmal machen und erklären
Einfach clap-E starten mit 5
Sehr gute Idee
Count, dann kannst du einfach
Cat-10 noch hinten dran hauen. Sehr gute Idee,
Push4D.
Sehr gute Idee.
Noch besser als meine Sache.
Also, Chat, nächste Aufgabe.
Oder nochmal erklären, nochmal langsam
mit erklären, wie die Leute Linux
lernen wollen. Ihr müsst mir das schon schreiben, weil sonst mach ich einfach
weiter.
Maxon gibt es neue Emotes
Oh ne hör mal auf
Ich weiß ich bin im Verzug
Ich habe übrigens einen Strafzettel bekommen
Da steht dass sie mir das demnächst zuschicken werden
Ich habe angeblich auf einem grünen Streifen geparkt
Da war halt nichts grün
Und es war erlaubt dass man parkt
AWK MonkaS
Okay, also Chat sagt, weitermachen.
C-Groups Problem
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt wird's eklig.
Z-API
Oh
Das hört sich aber schon traurig an, oder?
Die VM
Runnt die traurige
Api. Richtig sad.
Also auf dieser VM läuft
sad Api.
Port 9090.
Nix?
Bist du dir sicher?
Ja.
Du fährst doch primär Rad?
Nee, ey, ich jogge mehr, als ich Rad fahre.
Aber was meinst du?
Ach, ob das auch für Räder gilt?
Ich würde mal schon sagen, ja.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Aber ja, ich denke schon, dass das auch für Fahrräder gilt.
Letztendlich gelten Verkehrsregeln genauso für Fahrräder.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also, wir starten das mal.
Das könnte sein, dass ich hier verkacke.
Okay.
Vielleicht verkacke ich auch nicht.
Meint ihr, da tut sich jetzt noch was?
Oder ich hab's kaputt gemacht?
Komm, wir warten mal 50 Sekunden.
Vielleicht geht's ja.
Was hast du das mit dem Commerzbank-Tower mitbekommen?
Ne.
Ich hab nur mitbekommen, dass es letztens...
...gebrannt hat.
In...
...in Frankfurt irgendein Wohnhaus ist abgefackelt.
Und das habe ich gesehen tatsächlich von uns aus.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert, wo der ganze Qualm herkommt.
Okay, ich glaube, es ist kaputt.
Chat, ich glaube, wir haben das kaputt gemacht.
Ja, wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
WTF? Das Szenario ist kaputt.
Chat, ich glaube, wir können das Szenario nicht machen
Das ist broken
Das ist nice, wenn dir das was bringt
Das freut mich
Okay, Chat, wir können leider
Die letzte Easy-Aufgabe nicht abschließen
Die ist gerade broken
Dann machen wir weiter
Jetzt kommt eine Medium-Aufgabe
Nee, Leute, nee
Nicht, Chat, Chat
Nee, nicht wieder SSL-Zertifikate
Das hat mir einmal für heute schon gereicht
Not another
Disk Space Szenario
Haben wir das das letzte Mal abgebrochen
Oder so, warum ist das auf X
Nee, das haben wir doch gemacht
Ich kann mich da sogar noch dunkel
dran erinnern, wenn nicht, wir machen es einfach nochmal
Wir machen es einfach nochmal
Moin
Okay, Description
There is a home admin key high program
Make the changes necessary so it runs successfully without deleting the home admin data file
Okay
Nein, wir benutzen kein OpenStack
Nee, kein SSL
Du willst das nur, dass du wieder glänzen kannst, was du für OpenSSL-Kommandos auswendig kannst.
Gibt's zu.
Warum nicht?
Weil wir... Warte mal.
Weil wir hauptsächlich Managed Kubernetes-Clustern bei Google haben.
Oder ganz viel VN-Werk-Krempel.
und VMware hat auch so eine eigene
Kubernetes-Plattform
mittlerweile, die wohl
nur so semi-geil ist von dem,
was ich bisher gehört habe.
Sag mal,
ist der Server gerade kaputt?
Das letzte Szenario ging nicht,
das dauert jetzt hier schon ganz schön lang.
Nicht, dass das gebroken ist.
Nicht, dass Chat, nicht, dass wir es kaputt
gemacht haben.
Hey, wie siehst du eigentlich die Zukunft des Softwareentwicklerberufs?
Ist ja echt crazy, was durch die KI in dem Beruf abgeht.
Also ich sehe das nicht so, dass Entwickler arbeitslos werden durch KI.
Ich gehe stark davon aus, dass KI sich die nächsten Jahre noch viel mehr in den Alltag integrieren wird.
Aber ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es komplett neue Jobs geben wird.
Ja, sowas wie, ich weiß nicht, wie das dann heißen wird.
KI-Cleanup-Engineer
oder sowas.
Der sich den ganzen Kämpel anguckt, was die
KI da fabriziert und da was ordentliches draus baut.
Also da wird sich sicherlich noch ein bisschen was ändern.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass alle Entwickler
jetzt irgendwie arbeitslos werden oder sowas.
Das halte ich für Blödsinn.
KI-Kindermädchen.
Ja, sowas.
Ich meine, das ist auch auf der anderen Seite, so im Admin-Bereich,
ist das mittlerweile viel mehr im Tag integriert.
Wir haben glücklicherweise mittlerweile auf der Arbeit eine Copilot-Lizenz.
Das ist ein bisschen besser als diesen anderen privaten Chat,
den wir da von Google und Microsoft haben.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Also ich fragte öfters Dinger.
Gerade so Sachen hier mit OpenSSL-Commands, wie wir es vorhin hatten.
Der Charme am Beruf geht irgendwie etwas verloren.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen, ja.
Ja, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Das kann ich nicht richtig beurteilen, das kann ich nachvollziehen und könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass das so ist, ja.
Mittlerweile sind Tokens schon so teuer, dass manche Unternehmen schon wieder gesagt haben,
das ist es ja günstiger, jemanden einzustellen für.
Okay, also
Auf geht's
Hier ist ein Programm, das läuft nicht
Okay, schauen wir mal
Bam
Ein Go-Programm
Und warum läuft es nicht?
Wo soll ich wissen, was das macht?
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt eigentlich machen würde?
Ich würde jetzt zu dem Anwendungsverantwortlichen gehen
Und sagen, Alter
Was ist das für ein Log-Output?
damit kann ich nichts anfangen.
Guck du mal.
Aber anscheinend
ist die Festplatte zu
voll.
Anscheinend ist die Festplatte zu voll.
Wir können mal versuchen, also
Go-Programm kannst du dir halt nicht angucken.
Ist halt Binary, geschwummelt.
Was wir machen können ist,
wir können mal mit S-Trace starten
und mal gucken, ob wir irgendwo
was sehen, wo es abkackt.
Es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ja.
Also mit S-Trace siehst du quasi, was für Kernelaufrufe hier passieren.
Solltet ihr eine Datei sehen, die er versucht zu erstellen, sagt mir mal Bescheid.
Ähm.
Hä?
Aha, hier, guck mal.
Home Admin.
Home Admin Data
New Data File
Size, hier guck mal
Hier, der will
File Allocate
Oder sowas macht der
Und
Und dann will er das hier anlegen
Vermutlich
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal
S-Trace ist immer ganz abartig.
Ganz abartig.
Da kommen wir jetzt mal.
Pass auf.
Fahr mal die Chinesen-KI.
Was geht...
Was, was, was?
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Was geht hier schief?
Was sagt die Chinesen-KI?
Oh, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
S-Trace.
Minus E.
Und dann das hier so.
Pfeil.
Ah.
Cool, man muss sich da gar nicht durchhangeln.
Ah, das ist nice.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Siehste, Chat, ich lerne hier ja auch immer was.
Also, der will auf jeden Fall hier irgendeine Datei erstellen.
So, und ich vermute mal, dass hier, dass das die File Size ist oder sowas.
Oh, oh, es, es, es, es, ChetGPT weiß schon sofort Bescheid.
Der eigentliche Fehler steht ganz am Ende.
Äh.
Okay.
Ja, dann.
Anschließend, wait.
Okay.
Was, irgendwo in Main-Go-Zeile 64?
Was? Alter!
Wie, wie?
Wie, ich hab den Source-Code nicht, chat, gpt.
Okay.
Okay, wir machen das so.
Erkläre mir die Parameter.
Okay, SC-Mode.
Okay, Chat-GPD ist da wieder.
Was ist ST-Size?
Aha.
Ist das die Größe, die der versucht?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was versucht der denn hier aufzurufen?
Er versucht zumindest eine Datei anzulegen, die New Data File heißt und wahrscheinlich ist zu wenig Platz.
Das ist das, was ich mir hier so darunter vorstellen kann.
Hier, was das für Parameter bedeuten, keine Ahnung.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Was die Parameter bedeuten.
Path Name, Stat Buff.
Okay, nice.
Aber wir haben vier Parameter.
Aber danach macht er...
Aber danach...
Ja, ja, der will die öffnen.
Aber danach macht er...
Ähm...
Allocate.
Irgendwas.
Also, der versucht irgendwas...
Guck mal hier.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Der versucht, die anzulegen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
der versucht, die anzulegen.
Boah, er guckt ja,
ob die nicht da ist.
Ey, also ich würde drauf tippen,
der versucht, die anzulegen.
Wir können ja mal...
Just for fun.
Touch.
Und jetzt soll man ausführen.
Achso, Moment, Admin-Data.
Touch, Data.
New Data File.
Joa.
Aber ich glaube, ohne Mist, ich glaube, der will,
Man erkennt es jetzt hier nicht so genau.
Ich glaube, da will
wirklich
das Ding
anlegen.
Die Ausgabe
ist jetzt anders. Ja klar, weil es die Datei gibt.
Aber hier unten wieder. Also ich würde sagen,
der will die anlegen. Gehen wir mal von
aus, es ist wirklich zu wenig
Platz auf der Festplatte.
Ja, die letzte funktioniert.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Also, S-Trace-Sachen sind immer eklig zu lesen.
Ach, du meinst das hier? Stimmt, das hat funktioniert. Du hast recht.
Ja, das hat funktioniert.
Tja.
So, also, was
schreiben die hier sonst noch in der Aufgabe?
Without deleting
home admin data file.
Okay, wie groß
ist data file?
Data file ist 5 Gig.
Ich frage mich,
ob das ein Cheatbait ist.
Ich frage mich, ob das ein Cheatbait ist.
Ist das denn jetzt weg?
Ach, guck mal, der löscht die auch.
Der löscht die auch wieder.
Der löscht die auch wieder, die Datei.
Wenn die da ist.
Weil, guck, jetzt ist es wieder leer.
Moment.
Also, wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Wir gucken jetzt mal kurz was.
Was ist...
So, das ist ein X4.
Okay, das könnte man theoretisch halbwegs erweitern.
Ja.
Könnte man halbwegs erweitern.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Ist das...
Okay, das ist ein X4.
Das ist keine...
Das Bios ist okay.
Guck mal, wir haben hier noch
NVMe1
N1 und NVMe2
N1. Wir haben hier noch
zusätzlichen Storage.
Bringt uns das was?
Bringt uns zusätzlicher Storage was?
Bringt uns zusätzlich der Storage was?
Okay, der findet das.
Das ist okay.
Ne, das passt schon.
Und hier löscht er es.
Und hier löscht er die Datei immer.
Die ist halt schon weg.
So.
Bringt uns das irgendwas?
Ich würde sagen, wir machen da jetzt mal
Okay, ich habe eine Idee
Der versucht ja unter
Slash Data was zu schreiben
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal
Weil wir haben ja hier noch zwei Festplatten
Wir haben noch zwei Festplatten
Mit
jeweils einem Gig.
Da machen wir doch jetzt einfach mal
ein XFS drauf.
Konnte man nicht mit XFS direkt ein Stripe machen?
Ging das nicht?
Ansonsten müssen wir irgendwie
ein Raid oder so machen.
Äh.
Konnte man mit ZFS
nicht direkt ein Raid 0 machen?
Ne, anscheinend nicht, oder?
Da müssen wir MD raid.
Na gut, dann machen wir ein LVM.
Dann machen wir ein LVM.
Also, PV.
PV create.
Auf Dista und Dista.
Okay.
Wie geht das jetzt?
11, ne, ne, ne.
VG create.
Oh Gott, das weiß doch keiner auswendig
Blub
Und dann das da irgendwie
VGS
Okay, jetzt haben wir was
LV create
Minus L, 100% free, oder?
Blub
Ne
Äh, minus L
Okay, Alter, dass ich den Scheiß aus dem Kopf
Hinkrieg
Da ist aber ein 2 GB LVM.
MKFS, X4 oder XFS ist egal.
DevMapper.
Blub.
Woll, ja.
Gut.
Mount.
DevMapper.
Nach Home Admin Data.
Habe ich jetzt Rechte da überhaupt drauf?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Dann machen wir den Klassiker.
TH-Mod 777.
Home.
Home Admin Data.
Okay.
Data.
Touch.
Okay, Funst.
Easy.
Speicherplatz hat gefehlt.
Guck mal, was er jetzt macht bei S-Trace.
Er macht im Prinzip genau das gleiche.
Man sieht es nicht.
Was sagst du?
Mit Minus F kann man Unterprozessen folgen.
Das ist zum Beispiel.
Uiuiui.
Ah.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Hätte ich das vorher noch gefunden, dann wäre es easy gewesen.
Aber ich habe einfach mal predicted, dass das der Speicherplatz ist.
Okay, das habe ich gesucht, genau.
Dass ich sehe, wie der Aufruf aussieht.
Das habe ich vorhin gesucht.
1,5 Gig.
Ja gut, dann ist keine Frage, warum das jetzt klappt.
Weil jetzt haben wir ja Home Admin Data eingehängt mit 2 Gig.
Easy.
Chat.
Konnte man allem folgen?
Oder wollen wir das nochmal kurz durchgehen?
Was?
Exek, Snoop.
Snoop.
Von BPF Trace Tools.
Wird dir bestimmt gefallen.
Das tracet alle Exek Calls.
Siehst du also alle gestarrten Prozesse.
Das ist nice.
Das ist aber anscheinend nicht...
Das muss man wahrscheinlich...
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich da was installieren darf.
BP.
Ich muss erst mal Update machen.
Oh doch.
Nee, darf ich nicht.
Darf ich nicht.
Search.
BP, wie heißt das? BP?
F-Trace
Das da?
Nochmal durchgehen, okay, mach ich.
Okay, und jetzt
mache ich dann
exec
snoop. Ne, das ist da nicht drin.
Oder darf man das nur als root machen?
Ah.
Okay.
Äh, muss ich
Kernelheader oder irgendwas installieren?
äh, Linux
heißt das einfach Linux-Header unter Debian?
Colonel Dev oder irgendwie so?
Linux-Header, sage ich doch
ach so, ah mit dem
Mit dem hinten dran.
Linux Headers.
So dann?
Oder?
Alter.
Linux Headers.
Linux Headers AMD 64.
Ah ja.
Müllen wir erstmal die AWS-VMs hier zu.
Und 3 GB installieren.
So und jetzt?
Ah.
Und jetzt?
Okay, manchmal langsam.
Das advancede Tools müssen langsam sein.
Sonst sind sie nicht advanced genug.
Ich esse mal ein paar Johannisbeeren.
Also das ist schon enorm langsam gerade
Jetzt probieren wir es nochmal aus
Also ich erkläre nochmal was ich gemacht habe
Also
Es geht jetzt ja
Ich bin davon ausgegangen
Also man sieht
Ich zeige das nochmal
Also man sieht hier
Wenn man S-Trace ausführt mit diesen Optionen, S-Trace führt quasi ein Programm aus und lockt, welche Kernelaufrufe das macht.
So, und da sieht man unter anderem, dieses Programm ruft F-Allocate auf, Allocate, also File, damit erstellt man Dateien,
mit den Optionen minus L, das ist für die Size, und 1,5 Gigabyte.
Das heißt, er will eine Datei erstellen mit 1,5 Gigabyte, hier unter Home, Admin Data, New Data File.
Und das funktioniert nicht, weil auf der Root-Festplatte quasi so gut wie kein Platz mehr ist.
Sogar null available.
Ach, kann das sein, dass ich das jetzt voll geschrieben habe mit meinem Tracing hier?
Ne, keine Ahnung
Es ist zumindest kein Platz mehr auf der Rootplatte
Was ich dann gemacht habe ist
Ich habe mit FTS-L geguckt
Was noch für Festplatten im System hängen
Habe festgestellt, es gibt noch
Zwei SSDs
Mit jeweils einem Gigabyte Speicher
Und aus diesen zwei
SSDs
Habe ich dann ein Logical Volume gebaut
Oder ein Volume Group
Und darin ein Logical Volume
Was insgesamt
dann 2 GB enthält. Also quasi
1 GB plus 1 GB.
Dann habe ich hier einen Logical Volume.
Habe das formatiert mit Ext4.
Und eingehängt unter
Home Admin Data. Da wurde
versucht, diese Datei zu erstellen.
Jetzt habe ich unter Home Admin Data
Platz.
Beziehungsweise
nicht mehr so viel Platz, weil
schon die Datei erstellt wurde.
Aber dann war Platz und dann ließ es sich ausführen.
Guck, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe,
bam, funktioniert.
Weil Platz.
Gut,
Chatge.
Dann hätten wir es.
Schauen wir mal, ob das auch funktioniert.
Ob der auch sagt, dass das stimmt.
Easy.
Zack, next.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Hat er denn jetzt auch erkannt,
dass ich das richtig gelöst habe?
Ja.
Wir machen keine SSL Troubles.
Ich sag's euch, da hab ich jetzt keinen Nerv drauf.
Wir gucken mal, ob das C-Groups-Problem wieder funktioniert.
Ne, ist immer noch brocken.
Also, was haben wir denn als nächstes hier?
An mit Mr. Jazon.
Okay, also, was haben wir denn hier?
Using the file stationinformation.json
Find the station ID where kiosk is false and capacity is greater than 30.
Save the Station ID of the Solution
unter My Solution File.
Okay.
Ja, das krieg ich immer hin.
Das krieg ich immer hin, Leute.
Das geht bestimmt super easy
mit JQ, aber
ganz im Ernst, wer kann sich
die JQ-Syntax merken?
Ich muss da jedes Mal googeln.
Alter, JQ-Syntax ist
aus der Hölle. Die checkt niemand.
Run.
Chat, wenn ihr wollt, hier könnt ihr mitmachen.
Ansonsten bin ich ja immer ein bisschen
allergisch, was so Backseating angeht.
Also wenn es, wenn es,
nicht pauschal, aber wenn es
total
übertrieben ist, ja. So nach dem Motto
Max macht da jetzt den Parameter dran, mach mal hier,
guck mal da rein, das geht mir immer auf den Sack.
Da dürft ihr jetzt aber mal mitraten,
wie ihr das am
besten machen würdet.
Also so wie ich mich kenne,
wenn da Ruby drauf wäre,
würde ich wahrscheinlich mal wieder was mit Ruby
machen. Nee, aber wenn Python drauf ist,
da ist mir das wahrscheinlich am liebsten,
ein kleines Python-Skript zu basteln,
bevor ich mich,
bevor ich mich mit JQ
da durchwühle. Wir können
aber mal Chat-GPT fragen, was
das sagt, wie das mit JQ funktioniert.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich will das nicht,
ich will das nicht vibe-coden. Das ist,
das ist irgendwie
gecheatet.
JQ hat sehr interessante Syntax, wenn das sehr advanced werden soll.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Die JQ-Syntax ist wirklich Painstamp.
Ich kann mir mit Achtung krachen merken, dass man so einzelne Felder, also von Objekten in Arrays auslösen kann und sowas.
Das ist echt eklig.
So, yes.
Also, wir haben jetzt eine Datei.
Wo? Da.
Da ist sie.
Also, cat station information.json
Pipen wir das mal nach JQ.
Da kriegen wir...
Oh, das ist aber ordentlich.
Das ist aber ordentlich Output.
Also, was sollen wir jetzt machen?
Wir sollen uns rausholen.
Also, Chat, wenn...
Any IQ...
JQ...
High IQ JQ Checker
im chat können ihr mit dem könnte mit jayson kürzer sagen ansonsten gucke ich
mal wie ich das hinkriege oder irgendwie peisen will sich was zusammen burschelt
also station ist safe to stay also wir suchen etwas wo es kiosk falls ist und
capacity ist kreativ und es gibt es so nummer das richtig verstehe es gibt nur
eine Station-IT, die
Heskiosk
Falls hat.
Und dann die
Capacity größer.
Moment.
Moment. Wir machen das
ganz anders.
Wir machen das ganz anders.
Yep.
Heskiosk.
Wir machen jetzt
The Bash Way.
Machen wir jetzt.
Heskios Falls
Okay, das, Leute
Das können wir cheesen
Das können wir richtig hart
Das können wir richtig hart cheesen
Das hier
Das hier ist es
Ich geh mal davon aus, das hier ist relativ unique
Oh, ein Bunker W
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es relativ unique ist, dieser String da drin.
Ups.
Oh.
Ja, das gibt es nur einmal.
Wo ist die Station ID, Chat?
Äh.
Bin ich jetzt blöd? Wo ist die Station ID?
Die doesn't know.
Fünf Zeilen?
Ah!
Ich hab mich nicht gesehen.
Okay, und jetzt sollen wir was?
Das in my solution echon, okay.
Irgendwie hab ich den Eindruck,
ich hab ein bisschen gecheatet gerade.
Weil ich hab's mir einfach nur rausgekrippt
Mit ein paar Zeilen davor und dann manuell rausgesucht
Aber manchmal muss man einfach wissen
Wie
Easy
Ich kann das übrigens nur empfehlen, Leute
Es muss nicht alles immer
Geskriptet oder
super krass gejagued werden.
Ihr könnt auch einfach
Klappverwenden oftmals.
Gerade in Kombination.
Ihr klappt was und dann könnt ihr sagen,
bevor, das zeigt dann zwei Zeilen
vor dem Match an
und mit A zwei Zeilen
nach dem Match.
Das reicht oftmals an Kontext, dass man das
findet, was man sucht.
Und JQ ist trotzdem sinnvoll,
weil JQ
dass Jason ordentlich formatiert.
Deswegen kann man kreppen. Wenn das alles eine Zeile ist,
kann man da drin nicht gut kreppen.
So. Ich glaube, das muss ich nicht nochmal
erklären. Das hat man bestimmt verstanden.
Dieses Szenario. Das war jetzt nicht so kompliziert.
Next.
Oh nein.
Wo haben wir sie?
Ich hab doch so ein
Das ist das Bayern Emote
Hatte ich nicht irgendwo
Chat ich find mein Franzosen Emote nicht
Da ist es.
Die Suche ist doch kaputt.
Also, eine CSV-Datei.
Was soll ich machen?
Wir starten es erstmal.
Wir sollen Electoral District name nom de... was auch immer.
That has the largest number of rejected ballots.
Was sind denn Ballots?
Sind das so... so Ringe?
Sind das so diese Kugeln? Diese kleinen Kugeln?
Ach, Stimmzettel.
Okay, ne. Stimmen.
and also has a population of less than 100.000.
The initial CSV-File may be corrupt or invalid in a way that can be fixed without changing its data.
Was?
Corrupt or invalid in a way that can be fixed without changing...
Was auch immer.
Okay, jetzt wird's...
advanced.
Mal gucken, ob wir da mit unserem Gekreppe immer noch zu Potte kommen.
Mal gespannt.
Chat, ich hoffe, ihr freut euch, dass es mal wieder einen Samstagabend-Nachmittag-Abend-Stream gibt.
Ich weiß, die Zeit ist nicht die beste.
Da sind immer viele Leute nicht am Start.
Aber muss auch mal wieder sein.
Für alle, die am Start sind, ist es doch nice.
Und ich freue mich auch, dass sie so zahlreich mit am Start sind.
So.
Dann gucken wir doch mal.
Also, wir haben hier eine Datei, die da...
Table... Tableau.
Die ganz furchtbar eklig aussieht.
So.
Wir sollen die Electoral District
nehmen.
Oh Gott, das wird
eklig.
Moment.
Was zum Teufel ist Miller?
Miller ist
a command line tool for querying,
shaping and reformatting
data files.
Okay, dann kann man CSV zu JSON konvertieren.
Ist da ein JQ drauf?
Ne.
Ach du Scheiße.
CSV.
Ja, AF-Programme, mir ging es heute auch tatsächlich nicht gut.
Oder nicht so gut.
Ja, das war schon früher viel, viel schlimmer.
Geht heute alles klar.
Dann schauen wir da nochmal rein.
Also CSV-Dateien.
Die sind tatsächlich Komma-separated.
Das ist gut, dass die Komma-separated sind.
Dann machen wir mal ganz kurz das Ding hier.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Also, Electoral District.
Also, die zweite.
Die zweite Spalte ist es.
Also, könnte ich jetzt nicht sowas sagen wie Cat?
K-D,
Field 2.
Sowas hier?
Das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren, oder?
Wobei,
das ist doch viel einfacher.
Ich such
The largest number of rejected
Ballots.
Äh.
Moment, woher weiß ich, was Rejected Ballots sind?
Ah, hier.
Ne, Valid.
Rejected.
Hier.
Rejected Ballots.
Also, lass mal zählen.
Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
Vier.
Fünf.
Sechs.
Sieben.
8,
9,
10.
Die 10. Zeile sind
Rejected Ballots.
Wenn die Spalten selber kommen,
das ist natürlich ein Problem, ja.
Da sollte man doch Miller verwenden.
Aber wir gucken mal,
ob wir das so hinkriegen.
Das ist D.
Komma.
Äh, Quatsch.
Ich will das doch nicht mit Wim aufmachen, Alter.
Äh.
Ist das richtig?
Chat?
Oh nein!
Fuck, jetzt hab ich's irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Okay.
Ja doch.
Ah!
Okay, das fand ich richtig.
Das muss man mit einem CSV-Parser machen,
sonst dreht man echt am Rad.
Chat, ich hab ne heftige Idee, das zu cheesen.
Was heißt cheesen?
Guck mal.
Pass mal auf.
Wie da ist es mit Vorschlägen?
Ja, wenn ihr Vorschläge habt, haut rein.
Ähm.
Hier, Blutpunkt CSV.
Ich habe einen Pro-Account, ja.
In eine DB laden und Query ausführen.
Oh, das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Ich hätte gesagt,
ich mache das einfach
in Open Office auf.
Oh, oh, der Parse hat ein Problem.
Entity, Line 1, Parse Error, Document is empty.
Okay.
Aber der hat es wahrscheinlich schon gefixt.
Der hat es schon gefixt.
Okay, so.
Und jetzt brauchen wir...
Äh.
Wie Track und Drop.
Wir brauchen jetzt...
Äh.
Das ist kaputt.
Nein, hier. Rejected.
Rejected.
Äh.
Ah, Chat, wie sortiert man hier drin was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Jemand einen Plan?
Sort oder so?
Okay.
Meine Office-Skills
klappen schon mal nicht.
Meine Office-Skills sind zu procken.
Data-Tab
Wo ist das, wo ist das Data-Tab?
Ne, ne, Chat, Chat, ich bin
Ah
Eigentlich wird das da
Data
Ah, falsch rum.
Okay, also was sollen wir finden?
Okay, also die größten rejected haben, aber eine Population kleiner 100.000.
Was ist... Welche Spalte?
Kann man sich nicht die Spalte hier einblenden lassen?
Was ist hier?
Population?
Gott.
Seht ihr hier Population irgendwo?
Population, da.
Hier.
Okay.
Also wir suchen jetzt im Endeffekt...
The largest number...
Also, largest number here...
Hier, das da.
Aber da gibt es mehrere.
Da gibt es mehrere.
Guck mal, da gibt es mehrere.
Also im Prinzip die largest number.
Ja gut, dann
das hier, ne? Dann die hier.
Die haben die largest number.
Heißt im Endeffekt
das da.
Montkalm oder was muss da rein?
Ja.
Wie heißt der Krempel?
Mont Calm.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Easy win!
Open Office hat uns gerettet, Leute.
Und das, obwohl ich absolut kein Blasen-Schirme von Office-Programmen habe.
dachte mir, das ist eine gute Sache für Office-Programme.
Aber das haben wir jetzt schon ein bisschen gecheest, oder?
Wir haben ein externes Programm verwendet.
Auf der anderen Seite, warum nicht?
Hat Max nicht immer Excel-User ausgelacht?
Nee, ich lache keine Excel-User aus.
Ich sage es sogar immer.
Excel ist das einzig sinnvolle Tool,
was in der ganzen Office Suite da drin ist.
Weil Excel die Idee der Sekretärin ist.
Okay.
Szenarios.
Next.
Wir dürfen jetzt nicht so viel machen.
Wir brauchen ja noch ein paar, ne?
Für die nächsten Tage.
Müssen wir ja noch ein paar Sachen machen.
Okay, was haben wir jetzt als nächstes hier?
Oh, den SSL hatten wir schon.
Where is my Web-Server?
Hack.
Oh je, Chat. Das war's für euch.
Hackermans. Wo sind die Hackermans?
Ctrl-Shift.
Dann sollte es sortierbar sein.
Ach, siehst du mal.
Also, ein Entwickler hat ein ganz wichtiges Passwort
auf seinen Web-Server gelegt.
local sport 5000 die can find a way to recover at the scenario is easy once you realize the
one trick ach du scheiße das ist das ist was mit mit trick 17 okay probier das
Mal gucken
Mal gucken, ob wir den Trick realisen
Ich bin immer schlecht drin, irgendwas zu realisen
Habt ihr mitgekriegt?
Der Core Utils
Rewrite
Rust Rewrite in Ubuntu.
Hat Ubuntu mal wieder kaputt gemacht.
Vor ein paar Tagen.
Für mich
ist das der sinnloseste
Rewrite überhaupt.
Den hat niemand gebraucht.
Ich verstehe wirklich den Sinn
davon. Ich habe schon oft gesagt,
hier, Coyotils Rust.
Also,
das Projekt ist der Meinung, sie wollen,
also, ich habe nichts dagegen, dass sie das
machen. Ja, das ist ja vielleicht,
in 15 Jahren ist das auch eine super Alternative.
wird das kann alles sein aber dass sie das bei ubuntu jetzt schon einbauen
gerade ubuntu was neben red hat eine so quasi der verbreitetsten server systeme
ist was dann du hast dann quasi so tools wie weiß ich ob ich sogar drin steht
was die für tools haben ja du hast dann so was wie
Hier, Cat,
CA-Mod,
CA-Own, CA-Root,
CP, Cat,
DD, die ganzen Sachen haben die in Rust
neu implementiert.
Ich verstehe den Sinn
nicht. Also, ja, jeder kann mit seiner Zeit
machen, was er will. Also gegen das Projekt
habe ich nichts. Warum Ubuntu das integriert, verstehe ich nicht.
Die haben immer wieder bei
Inkompatibilitäten zu den bestehenden Programmen
und core-utils das ist halt so ein ding
das meiste davon sind ja reine user mode sachen userland sachen das einzige was
vielleicht ein bisschen probleme macht ist sudo falls sudo dabei war ich glaube
sudo war da auch dabei und die sind halt seit 40 jahren oder so testet es gibt
Kaum Software, die mehr testet ist als das.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
So.
Also.
Wir sollen jetzt irgendein Passwort rauskriegen.
Von irgendeinem Entwickler.
Der sein Passwort vergessen hat.
Super.
Also.
Curl Localhost Port 5000.
Unauthorized.
Bam.
Habe ich Rootrechte?
Habe ich natürlich nicht.
Das wäre auch zu einfach, wenn ich gut recht hätte.
Gab es nicht letztens irgendeine
Pseudosicherheitslücke?
Ne.
Also.
He can't find a way
to recover it. This scenario is easy
once you realize the one
trick.
Puh.
Na, schauen wir mal.
PS aux.
Grepp. Läuft dann engine X.
Net stat.
Port 5000.
Okay, wir kriegen nicht gezeigt, was da läuft,
aber schau mal.
ETC.
Sehen wir nicht.
LS-A, ETC.
ETC.
Läuft da irgendwas, was nach Web-Server aussieht?
konnte man sich nicht nur direkt auf das läuft da irgendwas was nach webserver aussieht
ich sehe jetzt leid leid httpd war da gerade container container die doch
drauf oder so locker ist auch drauf was zum teil macht der docker drauf moment ich
kraft docker container starten dann bin ich auch automatisch gut auf dem server wait a minute
Sekunde.
Okay.
Darf ich ins Internet?
Okay, ich darf einfach Docker-Images ausführen.
Gibt doch auch Rootless-Docker. Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Rootless-Docker ist.
Aber wir schauen mal kurz.
ETC, Lite.
httpd
Ich darf das alles Rieten moment kommt in nebel
Ich darf das alles Rieten das ist schon mal wahrscheinlich nicht so schlau
Javascript alias
Ist das die Seite, die hier läuft?
Wow.
Ne.
Anscheinend nicht.
War da oben nicht Apache?
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ach doch.
Ah ja.
Conf available.
Was ist das denn?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Dann, was ist ein gutes...
Debian.
Docker, run.
Ich habe keine Sudo-Rechte.
docker run
genau
so, jetzt müssen wir uns aber erst nochmal was
mounten
wie ging das jetzt nochmal
gescheit, so, ich glaube man konnte es jetzt hier
einfach sagen, minus v
mounte mir
slash quasi nach
slash plupp
weil docker ist ja root
blub schon sind auf der kiste und können eigentlich machen was wir wollen
etc apache gibt es nicht netzwerk update können sogar alles nach installieren
ab install netzteil bin ich ganz sicher ob was nett nett nett netz
utils oder so
netz tools auch gott das kann wer soll das alles noch merken können
Ich war nah dran, oder?
Ich war relativ...
So, das geht jetzt gegen den Container.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt, wir können uns da auch
CH-Routen irgendwie drinne.
Okay, das hat nichts gebracht.
Ich habe gedacht, wir können uns nach Plupzea ruten.
Du hast recht, das ist noch viel cleverer.
Du hast recht.
Das ist noch viel schlauer.
Das ist noch viel schlauer so.
So, NetTools installieren.
NetStats.
Okay.
Wir wissen aber immer noch nicht, welches...
Ich will wissen, welches Programm dahinter hängt, Alter.
Grab-i
HTTP.
Was?
Es gibt Sachen...
Alter.
Ich weiß nicht mal,
mit was man das installieren muss überhaupt.
Ich wusste, ich wusste
legit noch nie PS nachinstallieren.
Okay, da läuft
nix.
Oh, das
geht?
Hier ist ja gar nix drauf.
Ach, muss ich jetzt Port 5000 sagen, oder was?
Ne.
Ah, ja, stimmt.
Ich bin ja im Container.
Ich bin ja im Container, logisch.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, natürlich.
Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Also, wir sind jetzt schon mal Hut auf der Kiste.
Wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Wir geben uns einfach Sudo-Rechte.
Das dürfte das Einfachste sein.
Ne, warte mal.
Blub.
ETC, Wim.
ETC.
Dürfte wahrscheinlich das Einfachste sein.
Pseudo-Rs.
Es reicht wahrscheinlich auch,
wenn wir uns in...
Das ist ein Debian, ne?
Das reicht wahrscheinlich auch,
wenn wir uns in Wheel oder so packen.
Wo ist der Admin?
Was?
Es gibt keinen Admin-User.
Achso.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Ich habe den Container
aufgemacht.
Hier.
Könnten uns...
Wie heißt das Ding
nochmal unter Debian?
Wie heißt das?
Wheel?
Admin?
Wie heißt die Sudo-Gruppe nochmal unter Debian?
Sudo.
Einfach nur Sudo.
Ne, ne, ne.
Die heißt nicht immer Sudo.
So heißt sie immer Wheel und sowas.
Wo war das jetzt nochmal?
Wo hat man die Gruppen eingetragen?
Ich meine, man könnte auch einfach sagen User-Mod, aber...
Das war doch...
Das war doch Pass-WD.
Das war doch hier das zweite irgendwie.
Da, wo das X steht.
Guck mal.
C-Pass-WD-Groups.
Oder war das unter ETC-Groups?
Wo man dann den User reinschreiben musste.
Ist das so selten von Hand?
Ja, so, so ging das.
Okay, so ging das.
Sudo.
Moment.
Moment, der Admin hat Sudo-Rechte?
Ah, der Admin weiß das Passwort nicht.
Ich weiß das Passwort vom Admin.
Der Admin hat Sudo-Rechte, aber ich weiß das Passwort nicht.
Also, dann machen wir Pass-WD.
Ach, ne, Moment, ich bin ja noch im Container.
Kann man PassWD?
PassWD?
Ein File Specify?
Ansonsten kann ich das einfach selbst hashen.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Sudos?
Defaults?
allow members of sudo execute
ah ja
kann man jetzt hier
ich müsste da eigentlich Rechte drauf haben
kann man dem hier sagen
all
so
all sudo
commands
Fingers.
Ah ja.
All.
Habe ich so richtig.
Okay.
Ja, denn?
Jetzt sollte ich alles ausführen dürfen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das für die gleich ist.
Easy.
Wir sind gut.
Also, was läuft denn hier?
Python.
5 Angst, dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Python läuft, Port 5000.
So, ich habe die ursprüngliche Aufgabe, by the way, schon wieder vergessen.
Ach, jetzt sollen wir das recoveren.
So, grep, Python.
Es läuft, homeadminwebserver.py.
Passwort ist FD...
Okay.
Äh, Chat.
Das liegt auch noch unter Home Admin.
Wir hätten uns das Ganze mit dem Container sparen können,
wenn wir einfach Web-Server-Pi gecuttet hätten.
Aber wir wussten es ja nicht.
Wir wussten es ja nicht.
Wir hätten einfach Web-Server-Pi cutten können.
Aber hier ist das Passwort.
Ähm
Je nach Einstellung
Ja, die hätten wahrscheinlich schon beim Chef geklingelt
Übrigens Chat, weil ich gerade
dran denke, Sellout-Modus
aktiviert
Bis zum 8.
Also quasi nur noch bis nächste Woche Mittwoch könnt ihr günstigen Storage und günstige Ukraine-Nusses über meinen Link kaufen bei Alternate.
Da gibt es einen eigenen Wubblos-Shop, wo die Preise auch nur über meinen Link gehen und nur über meinen Link gelten.
Ihr könnt im Profil hier auf das Bild klicken, dann kommt ihr dabei raus.
Oder Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate, ich glaube Ausrufezeichen Alternate im Chat geht auch.
Da kriegt ihr den Link, könnt ihr hingehen, könnt ihr euch das Ganze angucken.
Gibt ja alles mögliche, 8TB Platten, 4TB Platten.
Und Ukraine NASes, ihr bekommt hier einen Low Power x86 NAS oder einen Low Power, ich glaube Arm Base NAS.
Mein persönlicher Favorit ist allerdings das hier, beziehungsweise sind das hier.
Das ist eine x86 Kiste mit einem Low Power Intel CPU, 2,5G Netzwerkkarte, auch wenn es nicht da steht.
Und das Ding hat Quick Sync, also sprich ihr könnt Videos transcoden im Rahmen, ja, für so ein Einsteigergerät.
Also wer da drüber Linux-Distributionen streamen will, die man transcoden muss, könnt ihr das damit machen.
Und die haben auch Crypto-Extensions, das heißt ihr könnt auch eure Festplatten verschlüsseln und trotzdem ordentlich Bandbreite übers Netzwerk kriegen.
Also als Einsteiger-Nast ist das echt gut.
So, excellent.
Sehr schön.
Sellout-Modus durch.
Gleich mal aufschreiben.
Sellout.
Bei 3 Stunden 20 habe ich den gemacht.
Excellent.
Siehste?
Jetzt habe ich meine 5 Big Sellouts
diesen Monat schon geschafft.
Next.
Moin
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute
Ich hab bestimmt wieder die Hälfte übersehen
Moment, Moment, Moment
Creator Dashboard
Leon, dich hab ich ja gar nicht gesehen
Excellent Subscription
Oder ich hab's vergessen, dass ich's gesehen habe
Hi, thanks, auch am Start
Vorhin noch der Sinux und davor Gottes Abbild
Dankeschön für die Subs
richtig
proggen.
Gut.
Haben wir es mal wieder hingekriegt.
Nächste Aufgabe.
Also, was hatten wir
eben gemacht?
Den hier, ne?
Where is my web server?
Buenos Aires.
Kubernetes Pod Crashing.
Oh, da habe ich Angst, dass ich mich blamiere jetzt, Leute.
Ich mache hauptsächlich Kubernetes auf der Arbeit.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht hinkriege, Instant Kick, Mann.
Guckt der Chef zu.
Sagt er Dienstag, Max.
Du hast nicht mal die Medium-Set-Server-Aufgabe hingekriegt.
Du musst jetzt in die Personalabteilung und nur noch BWL machen den ganzen Tag.
so so so mit level kubernetes leute können wir nicht gibt unter mit level
kubernetes leute kann man nicht gebrauchen ab ab zu den buchhaltern
ok schau mal was ist denn die aufgabe könnte das übrigens aber starten es dauert ja
genau ich war immer noch abgelenkt im kopf von der von der open ssl vom zertifikat in
Also, es gibt zwei Ports, Logger und Logshipper.
Im Default-Namespace.
Warte mal, ich muss nochmal husten.
Unfortunately, Logshipper has an issue.
And it's forbidden to see what Logger is trying to say.
What?
Could you help fix Logshipper?
Do not change the Kubernetes definition of the Lockshipper-Pod.
Achso.
Ach, das darf ich nicht, weil das wäre das Erste, was ich gemacht hätte.
CubeCTL edit.
Moment, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt direkt auf lösen drücke, dann funktioniert das direkt.
Moment, Moment, pass mal auf.
Ah ne, okay.
Hätte ich eigentlich gedacht.
So ist...
Der fällt automatisch.
Kann das sein, dass wir das sogar
reported haben das letzte Mal?
Dass das ginge?
Mit direkt auf Solution klicken?
Das haben wir, glaube ich, sogar über Twitter reported
damals. Das haben wir rausgekriegt.
Dann haben wir das schon gemacht.
Das können wir nicht gemacht haben, wenn das ein Pro-Szenario ist.
Aber wir haben schon mal eine Sache reported,
wo wir einen Bug gefunden hatten.
Das war wahrscheinlich was anderes.
Kypernetis
machen wir jetzt.
Also, guck mal. Cube CTL
get pods minus A. Immer bestes Kommando
gleich mal. Sehr gut. Achso, ich soll
sudo use und steht auch da. Cube CTL
get pods minus A. Zack, alles da.
Geht
autocomplete? Nein, autocomplete nicht.
Geht nicht. Ich gebe euch mal
einen Tipp, Leute. Cube
CTL completion
Bash. Und dann
hier. So.
So. Source.
Und jetzt
CubeCTL.
Und jetzt habt ihr AutoComplete.
Inklusive Namen von Pots
und sowas. Ist das nicht nice?
Der da hier. Beste.
Hat man
das verstanden?
Weil das ist wirklich, du kannst CubeCTL ohne Autocomplete nicht gescheit bedienen.
Das ist komplett useless ohne Autocomplete, finde ich.
Du sagst halt hier, CubeCTL generieren wir Bash-Completion und die sourcest du halt direkt.
Okay, also hier, Crashloop Backup, der Lockshipper.
Also, guck mal
Es gibt ein Kommando
CubeCTL Completion
Für Bash, es gibt auch ZSH
Das generiert Bash Completions
Bash Completions
Das würdest du normalerweise in einer Basher-Case
Machen, aber du kannst
Für die aktuelle, also
Das hier leitet
Den Output von diesem Command
Um
An Standard
von einem anderen Command.
Per NamePipe. Das ist ein NamePipe.
Du sourcest quasi
den Output dieser NamePipe.
Das ist das gleiche.
Ich könnte es auch so machen.
Guck mal. Ich könnte es auch so machen.
Zack.
Blub.txt
Source.blub.txt
Okay.
Ich kann dir das auch mal zeigen.
guck mal hier, Echo. Da kommt jetzt
irgendwas mit NamePipe bei raus.
Guck. Das hier
wird dann eigentlich durch devfd63
ersetzt.
Und das sourced dann die Datei.
Also sourced dann die Datei.
Okay, also.
Als nächstes, cubectl logs.
Das Schöne ist, dass es im Namespace default ist.
Wir müssen nichts angeben. Gucken wir uns mal die Logs
vom Pod an.
Ja.
Da muss er nicht...
Logger? Ne.
Ah, der Log-Shipper.
Der Log-Shipper.
Logs kann man sich übrigens nicht immer angucken, wenn der Pod abkackt.
Ähm.
Also.
Reason forbidden.
Read namespace podlog.
What?
Ist da irgendwas?
Hier.
API Version 1.
Failure Message Pots.
Logger.
Ist verbitten.
User. Ah, der Service Account ist falsch.
Der Service Account ist falsch.
User, System, Service Account, Default, Log, Shipper, SR, Cannot, Get, Resource, Pod, Log in, Api, Crew.
Oder aber die Berechtigungen für den Service Account sind falsch.
Cube CTL.
Ne, das sieht...
Das sieht jetzt nicht nach Network Policy aus.
Gibt's auch keine.
Get.
Service.
Service Accounts.
Okay.
Logshipper.
Da ist er.
Okay, Cube CTL Edit.
Moment, ich darf das nicht editieren, oder?
Nee, ich darf nur die Ressourcen vom Pod nicht.
Was war die Aufgabe?
Zu gucken, warum der Lockshipper nicht funktioniert.
Edit, Service Account.
Oh, das mache ich ganz selten.
Service Account.
Lockshipper.
Default Namespace.
Ähm, okay.
Da muss ich jetzt ehrlich gestehen,
mit
Kubernetes
API-Berechtigung, das muss irgendwie wieder
Roll-Based
Access oder sowas? Oh, fuck.
Was deine
Chance, MaxCubeCTL, kann
im Kontext vom Service-Account
zu nutzen, richtig, falsch.
Was?
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Oh fuck, da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Was, Binding?
Ne, du meinst hier...
Oh Gott.
Das da meinst du, ne?
Oder so, Role-Based Access Control, irgendwas.
Oh Gott, hör mal bloß auf.
Das Gute ist, wir haben eine Google-Managed Kubernetes-Klasse, da musst du das nicht machen.
Da geht das über das Google-IRM.
Wenn du es richtig mappst.
Can I
zeig dir, welche Permissions du hast?
Ach.
Wie, einfach so? Oder was?
Nee.
Hab ich noch nie...
Oder hier?
Can I?
Nee.
Roll Bindings.
Rolls.
Ich sehe jetzt hier nichts.
Da gibt es keine...
Oh, shit.
Coop CTL Auth, can I?
Resource System Service Account.
Oh, das ist jetzt aber
advanceder shit, ey.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt googeln.
Da muss ich jetzt googeln.
Also, Logs, Logshipper.
Das eigentliche Problem ist ja quasi das hier.
Cluster-Roll-Binding.
Fragen wir mal.
Wie kann ich meinen Service-Account nutzen?
Ja.
Das hab ich noch nie benutzt.
Das klingt ja...
So, auto-completed das hier auch.
Nee.
Das wär ja zu geil, wenn das auto-completed, ey.
Get Service Accounts
S
Was muss ich jetzt angeben?
Default?
Oder wie? Default?
Service Account
Lockshipper SA
Oder wie? Oder was?
Ah
Oh, das ist ja nice
Das ist ja cool.
Okay, das könnte echt ganz praktisch sein.
Äh.
Wenn ich da was angebe, was es nicht gibt,
macht er genau das gleiche?
What the fuck?
oder muss das system angeben das habe ich schon nie ausprobiert okay
whatever.
Guck mal.
Hier.
Fiveheader.
Chat-GPT.
No.
Can I get Pots?
Lock as no.
Aber der Pot
heißt doch gar nicht
Lock. Der heißt doch
der heißt doch
Logger.
Aber das ist ja wieder
krasse Syntax hier.
No.
Ich weiß aber nicht,
ob ich die Syntax richtig angegeben habe.
Wenn ein No fehlt die R-Bug-Regel, ja das habe ich schon gedacht.
Okay.
Oh, the fuck, Kubernetes, Alter.
Oh, bin ich froh, dass ich so Rollenmanagement nicht machen muss.
Das sieht ja richtig aberhaltig aus.
Okay, was? Man kann doch bestimmt noch CubeCTL edit.
Was ist so? Cluster.
Cluster, Binding. Cluster, Roll.
Binding.
So, was haben wir da?
Also das ist, Chat,
auch wenn ich, ich mache ja recht viel mit Coins,
das ist wirklich auch komplett, komplett Blindflug
für mich jetzt.
Aha.
Guck mal hier.
Was haben wir da?
API?
So.
Kann ich hier sagen,
dass da auch der...
Was? VNOT implemented?
Ups.
Install Vim.
Moment.
Ist das...
Ist das Nano?
oder was was ist das für eine eklige editor
kann ich hier einfach what the fuck
eigentlich bin bei der versicherung
Export Editor gleich WIM.
Please.
Wenn möglich.
Ja, ja.
Schon gleich besser.
So, kann ich jetzt hier...
Kann ich hier unten jetzt einfach sagen...
Moment, da ist doch der Service-Account-Logschipper.
Und woher weiß ich jetzt, was der für...
Also das hier gilt...
Das hier gilt...
Für den Account-Logschipper.
So, Cluster-Roll.
Rolls.
Aha.
Resource.
Pots.
Locks.
Und woher weiß ich jetzt?
Welche?
Ah, das da.
Die hier müsste ich dann quasi da finden.
Log Shipper Cluster Roll, ne?
Die müsste ich dann quasi da drin finden.
Log Shipper Cluster Roll, da ist er doch.
So, also, der kann Ressourcen, Pots, Log, List.
So, List brauchen wir nicht, wir brauchen auch noch Get, vermutlich.
Fragezeichen.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Get. Okay.
Box.
Cannot get resource
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben es richtig gemacht jetzt
Ich glaube, wir löschen den Pot jetzt einfach mal
Und gucken, ob der dann richtig hochkommt
Cube CTL, delete
Äh, Pot
So, und jetzt sollte der richtig hochkommen
klar.
Das sieht doch gut aus.
Es scheint zu funktionieren, Leute.
Okay, das war auch für mich
komplett Plimpflug jetzt.
Aber das scheint zu funktionieren.
Das sagt ja Kubernetes,
das ist ein Fass ohne Boden, ja.
Bin ich froh, dass wir keine Cluster,
so, so, so, Brechungssachen
über Jammer-Files machen müssen.
Das geht glücklicherweise bei Google alles über das eingebaute Google-IRM.
Du musst eigentlich nur noch einmal
einen Google-IRM-Account auf den Service-Account mappen
und der Rest geht über Google.
Das ist ganz nice.
So, check my solution. Bam.
Geschafft!
16 Minuten, 36,
Sekunden.
Okay, Chat, ich lass euch jetzt
die nächste auswählen.
Die nächste Medium-Aufgabe, okay?
Also.
Ähm.
Warum nicht mal ne harte?
Ich dachte mir, wir machen's halt von oben, von unten.
Wir haben auch schon harte gemacht.
Das hier, das haben wir
verkackt.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal easy Aufgaben.
Also, welche
wollen wir machen? Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Restore my SQL.
Oh, please. No.
No.
Lass mich in Ruhe mit my SQL.
Oder Datenbankstells.
Okay, also wir können...
Also, was haben wir
zur Auswahl?
sagen wir mal so, wir sagen einfach mal, wir sagen einfach mal, okay, zwischen den 10 haben wir die Auswahl, okay, also restore mysql database, restore mysql database spooked by a ghost, handchart issue, how much do you press, prometheus can't scrape web server, security snack,
First Walls of Postgres
Physical Replication
Oh, nee
Supervisor still around
Engine X
Brotli
Brotli, das ist so ein Kompressionsding, glaube ich
XZLZM Library Compromised
Aha
Modify SQL 3 Database
Okay, Chat, was wollen wir haben?
29 klingt gut
Nee, 29 steht nicht zur Auswahl
Was wäre denn 29?
Find the Multitasking Users
Das steht gar nicht zur Auswahl
18, 20
Plan 18
Wollt ihr mir das wirklich antun?
Okay
Okay, 26
Wir machen 26
Wir machen die eh alle
Also jetzt nicht heute, ja
Das wird vielleicht ein bisschen viel
Aber wir machen die alle
Ja, das eben hat nicht gereicht, um deinen Kubernetes-Job zu securen. Das stimmt.
Wie gesagt, morgen Versetzung in die Personalabteilung. Nur noch BWL-Zeug.
Oder noch schlimmer.
Irgendwelche Abrechnungsbuchhaltungssachen.
Also, ein Developer.
Immer diese Developer.
Developer.
Yeah.
Developer, Developer, Developer.
Immer diese Developer.
Haben wir da nicht sogar ein Emote für?
Haben wir nicht sogar ein Ballmer Emote?
Wollen wir das mal kurz nachgucken.
Haben wir doch.
Also readdb.py, that tests access to a database without modifying the readdb.py file, changed
the database so that running the script returns the string john karmic.
Hast du jetzt mal Silicon Valley gesehen?
Ja
5 Minuten oder so
Nee, ist nicht schlimm.
Es ist schwierig, was zu finden,
wo ich mich wirklich weg-
kack-double-junen kann.
Also,
sehr explizit gemacht,
so Comedy-Sachen, die zum Lachen
gemacht sind, finde ich meistens gar nicht so lustig.
Dafür kann ich mich bei C++-Videos
kaputt lachen.
Also, readdb.py
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich gucke die erste Folge mal fertig, okay?
Ich glaube, das ist schon absichtlich,
dass sie den so geschrieben haben.
Okay, wenn man das hier ausführt,
dann geht das nicht, oder was?
No such column, timestamp.
Ich glaube, es läuft auf SQL-Kommandos raus.
Oh, ich habe eine Idee, Chat.
Fuck, wir haben keine Root-Rechte.
Haben wir einen Docker-Container zum Ausbrechen?
Wir hätten wieder einen Docker-Container zum Root-Werten, Leute.
Das wäre aber cheaten
Das machen wir nicht
Weißt du, was ich mir gedacht habe?
Ich könnte mir Dings installieren
Wie heißt das?
SQLite Browser oder so?
Browser?
SQLite Browser
Was macht das hier nochmal?
Select Name Timestamp from Users
where ID gleich 1.
Okay, heißt im Endeffekt
SQLite.
Und dann gibt man einfach
Users DB an.
Okay, select
Sternchen from
From was?
From users
Okay, siehste, bin ich schon mal
zu unfähig für wieder SQL
Ich muss ja jetzt bestimmt connect oder sowas
machen, hä?
Warte mal, nee, nee, nee, Moment
Das ist Postgres, das ist Postgres
Select Sternchen from zahlen hier alles database
Table
Ich bin sogar zu dumm und select zu machen aber
Ich muss gegen welche datenbank muss ich mich denn überhaupt connecten oder ging db fall
Warum geht das nicht?
No such table users.
What?
Äh.
Mach ich das...
Mach ich das überhaupt richtig?
Startet man das überhaupt so?
Ja, der würde ja schon...
Oh ja, jetzt legt er die Datei an, hä?
Dot Tables?
Machines gibt's da nur.
Moment, öffnet das überhaupt das Richtige?
User.db-File.
Machines?
Ja, es gibt nur das.
Aber.
Moment, es gibt Users.
Ich muss da einfach
einen Insert machen.
Ich muss da einfach einen Insert machen.
Oder create table oder sowas.
Select Sternchen from machines.
Okay.
Create table.
Oh Gott.
Hätte ich mal in der Berufsschule besser aufgepasst, Leute.
Create table.
So, wir brauchen eine Table mit Name und Timestamp.
Und mit ID.
ID ist automatisch, gell?
ID ist automatisch.
Ich mach das, ich lass mir jetzt einfach easy.
Die Tabelle.
Users gibt's nicht.
Wie?
Gebt mir ein SQL-Command zum Anlegen.
So.
Bäh.
Hi, mal was ganz anderes.
Ich betreibe Hobby-mäßig
ein was? Ein Store-Note?
Mit Debian
USB 3 hast du Tipps für USB 3?
Beine machen und die Latenz senken
bei vielen kleinen Dateien. Wahrscheinlich ist da
USB allgemein das Problem.
Slatency, die variiert halt ziemlich.
Hier. Create Table Users
ID, Int, Name, Text,
Timestamp.
Okay.
Dankeschön, Dankeschön, Chat, Chat, GPT.
Was?
Read-only-Database?
Warum ist die read-only?
Die ist überhaupt nicht read-
Lüg, lüg doch!
Ah!
Moment, die ist-
What the fuck?
Moment.
Muss ich doch per Docker-Container
wieder ausbrechen?
Die gehört dem...
Deswegen ist da Docker drauf, oder?
Ah!
Environment!
Man kann per Environment
setzen. Okay.
Export. DB-File.
Hackle.
Punkt.
DB.
SQLite.
Hackle. Punkt. DB.
Bam.
Select.
Sternchen. From.
Users.
Okay. Ist nichts drin.
So. Und was brauchen wir da jetzt?
Okay, den müssen wir hinzufügen.
Mit ID 1.
Also, insert.
Into.
Users.
Was weiß ich, wie das funktioniert?
Ich kann kein SQL aus dem Kopf machen.
Insert into
Users?
Okay, wir fragen jetzt einfach nochmal Chat-GPT.
Jetzt
will ich
einen User inserten.
Reines
SQL-Command.
Woher weiss der, dass ich Max heiße?
Was ist hier los?
Insert into users
Name, Timestamp
Leaked
Oder mit fester ID
Current Timestamp
Ist das irgendwie eine Variable oder so?
So und jetzt brauchen wir hier, das hat es irgendwie sich nicht gemerkt, wir brauchen
den hier, den müssen wir inserten.
Okay, wenn man jetzt noch richtig copy-pasten könnte.
Okay, jetzt ein select hinterher.
Wir haben es, Leute. Wir haben es.
Read DB.
Bam.
Ähm.
By the way.
Ich glaube.
Das geht nicht.
Genau.
Weil das Environment Variable ja nicht stimmt.
Ja, Chat.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
Cheap-Aided.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen Cheap-Aided.
Wir haben es gefixt, ja.
Aber
das Checkscript,
naja, eigentlich ist Checkscript bearbeiten
eigentlich ist Checkscript bearbeiten
Cheaten.
Aber das läuft doch bestimmt als Admin.
Mal schreiben wir es in die Bash-AC rein.
Ne, wobei, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Skripts führen keine Bash-AC aus, ne?
Skripts führen keine Bash-AC aus.
Ja, dann...
Ja, dann müssen wir doch wieder tricksen.
Also wir haben es eigentlich gefixt, aber nicht richtig.
Weil das hier die Environment-Variable nicht.
Okay, also wieder mal.
Docker, run.
Debian.
Aber ich habe keine
Root-Rechte. Ich habe keine Root-Rechte.
Das ist es ja hier. Keine Root-Rechte.
Wir können aber tricksen wieder.
Minus V.
Gemount nach
Slash-Blub.
Eventuell so.
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich nochmal gucken, aber glaube ich mal eher.
Was?
Aha, Export-DB-File.
Optusers-DB?
Moment, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Alter, das ist ja Cheap Aid, Mann.
Das ist ja Hardcore Cheap Aid.
Optusers
Cpkeckel.de
nach optusers.de
Ich hoffe, das kann ich jetzt einfach
überschreien.
Und read.
Okay.
Okay, pass.
Jetzt aber.
Das konnte man jetzt aber auch nur,
weil man sich das Checkscript angeguckt hat, ne?
Okay, gut.
So.
Okay.
Was hatten wir gesagt?
Machen wir als nächstes.
Endlich.
Okay, Chat.
Jetzt haben wir Auswahl hier dazwischen, okay?
Also, von 25 bis 35.
Was 29 war es?
Find the multitasking users.
Okay, das klingt ja schon mal ganz spannend.
Linux Server, large number of user accounts and groups.
The system administrator needs to identify which users belong to multiple groups for better access management.
Two files, users.txt, groups.txt.
Man soll ein neues File erstellen, das Usernamen der User enthält, die in mehr als einer Gruppe sind.
Na gut, das sollten wir doch hinkriegen.
33 als nächstes.
Also das machen wir jetzt.
Und dann 33. Was ist 33?
Lost in Translation. Okay.
Also die
weiß ich nicht, ob ich die jetzt noch mache. Die mache ich auf jeden Fall noch.
Aber wir sind ja schon wieder
4 Stunden am Start, Leute.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt wenigstens mal
auf meinen Link geklickt zu Alternate.
dass es in der Statistik gut aussieht.
Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate im Chat.
Könnt ihr mal zumindest draufklicken, dass es so aussieht, als interessiert es jemand.
Wobei wohl auch schon Leute drüber gekauft haben.
Hab ich gehört.
Habe ich mir vielleicht auch nur eingeredet.
Also was wollen wir jetzt machen?
Wir sollen aus Krups TXT die raussuchen,
Die mehrere Users...
Ne.
User, die in mehreren Gruppen sind.
So rum.
Ja, ne?
Finde ich auch.
Ich kriege nämlich Festpreis, egal wie viele Leute kaufen.
Was natürlich auch gut sein kann, wenn nicht viele Leute kaufen.
Ja, ich finde auch.
Ich wollte denen eh mal schreiben, ob die nicht nochmal was Neues auflegen können.
Mit Vorbehnasses und vielleicht auch mal fetten Platten.
So, da sind wir.
Also es gibt Users.txt
Und, das ist ja easy
Und Groups
Group.txt
Also, in Users.txt
Haben wir tatsächlich nur Username drinstehen
Und wir sollen jetzt rausfinden
Wer von diesen Usern
Quasi in mehr
Als einer Gruppe drin ist
Naja gut, das ist ja glaube ich jetzt nicht sonderlich schwer
4 User in Cat.
Ich weiß, das geht auch besser als Users TXT.
Blue Echo Dollar User.
Dann, okay.
Grab User in Groups TXT.
Echo, dass wir wissen, dass der Durchgang durch ist.
Okay.
Echo, Dollar, User.
Also.
Bob ist in drei Gruppen.
Charlie ist in...
Zwei Gruppen.
Und Eve ist in zwei.
Na gut, wir können übrigens einfach Crip-C sagen.
So, easy. Guck mal.
Mit Network Host Pit Host Privilege starten und als Container-Root laufen lassen.
Stimmt, ja.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob ich Minus Minus Privilege starten darf.
Ohne Sudo-Rechte.
Ich glaube, das direkt geht nicht.
Aber was gehen würde, ich könnte mir den
Docker-Socket in Docker mounten
und da drin einen Docker starten,
wo ich dann die Rechte wahrscheinlich hätte.
Ganz abgedrehter Shit.
Also, so, Bob.
Wir können es uns übrigens noch einfacher machen.
Wir lassen das hier weg.
Ups.
Naja, im Prinzip ist es easy.
Eve ist doppelt drin.
Charlie und Bob.
Und Bob.
Das sind die drei, oder? Seht ihr noch mehr?
Hans, alles eins hier.
Eve.
Eve, Charlie und Dings.
Ja.
Wir könnten jetzt noch was ganz ekliges machen, was eigentlich so nicht funktionieren würde, aber in dem Fall schon.
Crep minus V1.
Da sehen wir es ja nochmal.
Bob, Charlie, Eve.
Ah.
Und jetzt sagen wir hier.
Und, und, Echo, Dollar.
user
Und haben dann im endeffekt eine liste ich meine das ist jetzt super und unnötig guck jetzt haben wir hier bob charlie eve
Sollte ich das als sollte ich das alphabetisch sortieren
Wo steht es
Containing the user names of users who belong to more than one group
One username per line.
Okay.
Dort.
Bob, Charlie, Eve.
Und das Ganze jetzt nach was?
Nach?
Multi-Group-Users-CXT.
MD5-Summen.
Äh, okay.
Und Leerzeichen oder so?
Hä?
Bist du jetzt dumm?
Äh, Chat, das ist falsch, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da dran falsch ist.
Habe ich das irgendwie etwas falsch gelesen?
contain the usernames of users who belong to more than one group
one username per line sorted alphabetically
habe ich irgendwelche Leerzeichen da hinten dran
ne
Äh, das verstehe ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Habe ich da einen Denkfehler?
Habe ich da irgendeinen Denkfehler?
Nee, das ist
Wie das in dieser
Group CXT drin steht
Developer
Alter, das ist ja
Gemein
Das ist ja gemein
Eve muss raus
Wir können aber auch sagen
Head, Groups, TXT
Cut, minus D
Doppelpunkt
Feld, 2 bis
Guck, jetzt kommen noch Bob und Charlie raus
Wenn ich 1 bis sage, kommt wieder Eve mit dabei
Jetzt habe ich nämlich
den Gruppennamen, guck
So werfe ich den Gruppennamen weg
Das kommen nur noch die Zeilen mit den Usern
Da muss nur Bob und Charlie rein
Nur Bob und Charlie.
MD5 Summen.
Okay, das sieht besser aus.
Ja, jetzt stimmt's.
Siehste mal.
Da war doch ein Trick dabei, diesmal wieder.
Das ist halt ein Ding.
Das werdet ihr total oft bei irgendwelchen Bash-Frickeleien haben.
Bash ist halt wirklich nur Text.
Das hat keine Ahnung von der Syntax oder was da drin was bedeutet. Im Vergleich
zu PowerShell. Bei PowerShell geht das. Also bei PowerShell kannst du von einem Kommando an das andere
wirklich Objekte übergeben, wo du bisschen auch was von der Struktur noch drin hast.
Aber bei Bash ist es einfach nur pur Text.
Jawoll
Boah, das ist aber nicht schlecht gewesen
Das hat mich gebatet
Das Twitch-Doc wieder Twitch-Dinge
Okay
Was ist das hier? Vielleicht machen wir das noch
Vielleicht machen wir das noch
There is a docker container that runs
a web server on port 3000
but it's not working
Use the tooling and resources provided
in the server, make the container
run correctly
Wollen wir uns das noch geben?
Okay, Chat.
Ihr dürft entscheiden.
Machen wir noch oder machen wir nicht?
Okay.
Wir sind schon ziemlich kaputt jetzt.
Doch, doch.
Ich spiele ab und zu noch Sachen.
Lumpen, Magus.
Dankeschön übrigens für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Also der Docker-Container funktioniert nicht.
Curl port.
Curl auf Localhost 3000.
Wahrscheinlich ist das
irgendwelche komische
IP-Tables-Routing-Geschichte oder sowas,
die jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Ja, die Zeiten haben wir nicht mal ansatzweise immer erreicht.
Ja.
ist created.
Alles klar.
Aber man muss doch mal wirklich sagen, Leute,
das ist doch eine richtig gute Seite,
oder? Um was zu lernen,
um irgendwie neue Bewerber zu
testen oder so. Es ist richtig gut und richtig gut gemacht.
Also da müssen wir Chat einmal,
da brauchen wir einmal 07
für Set-Servers im Chat jetzt.
Auch wenn er es wahrscheinlich nie sehen
wird der ersteller alles echt gute seite eine eine runde setzer was auswerfen
gut sehr schön wie gesagt er wird wahrscheinlich nicht sehen
Also Curl 3000 geht nicht.
Bam.
Connection Refuse.
Dockers PS.
Restarting macht der Server.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe schon gar keine Ahnung mehr, wie Docker Sachen funktionieren, weil ich nur noch Kubernetes-Kram mache.
Okay.
Docker.
Web-Server.
Docker Images.
Gibt es sowas wie Docker Logs?
Logs.
Webserver.
Wow.
Formaterror.
Kann das sein, dass...
Das falsche Binary?
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie man Docker richtig verwendet.
Wie kann man sich da inspect oder so?
Wow, wow. Da kann man sich doch hier
Gedöns anzeigen lassen, oder? Also Image und so.
Hier.
Es startet
binsh python
app.py
Lass uns mal gucken.
Gibt es hier einen Docker-File oder sowas?
Gibt ein Readme.
Also Docker Inspect
Python
AppPy, ja gut, das ist
Ich würde
gerne wissen
sieht man auch welches Image der verwendet
Web-Server Latest.
Docker Images.
Hat der wirklich ein Image gebaut mit dem falschen Binary?
Aber das ist irgendein Python-Gedöns.
Das riecht aber nach Cross-Compile-Action hier.
Aber der führt ja nur eine Pi-App aus.
Na gut.
Docker Images.
Man kann sich doch das Image irgendwie antarren lassen.
Ich würde mal gerne in das Image reingucken.
Docker Images.
Docker Image Antar.
Das geht doch irgendwie.
How to extract files from an image.
Genau.
Docker Save!
Docker Save.
Web Server Latest.
Äh.
Oder was?
XFZV.
Ne, äh, Moment.
Windows V.
Macht das jetzt was?
Blub.tar
Ist das ein Tar oder ein Tar-GZ?
Ach, das ist nur ein Tar.
Macht das jetzt was?
Okay, wir können auch
CP'en. Ja, das ist alles gut.
Vielleicht können wir uns, vielleicht können wir uns
in das Image.
Okay, dann verbinden wir uns hier unten nochmal.
Docker,
exec,
so, ähm,
minus, minus,
diese Syntax, die,
ist restarting,
ah,
Der läuft ja gar nicht.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt so was sagen.
Cube CTL Edit Endlosschleife machen.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher,
ob man...
Kann man mit Docker
Container editieren, die schon laufen?
Das dauert zu lang.
Blubta.
Doch, das dauert.
Das dauert einfach so lang.
SebiDev, danke schön für den Sub.
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Wir sagen Docker run.
Docker run.
Bash.
Und jetzt Webserver.
Webserver Latest.
Ah, guck mal hier.
The Requested Image Platform.
Linux.
Ich habe doch richtig gelegen, falsche Plattform.
Also ich kann dem sagen, dass der mit minus minus was?
Minus minus Plattform?
Man kann Docker ja sagen, dass der eine andere Architektur ausführen soll.
Da gibt es doch eine. Dann starte ich es eben einfach als Arm.
Gibt es denn vielleicht
Gibt es vielleicht das Image auch als
Gibt es das Image vielleicht irgendwie auch als
Ne, das hat er
Das hat er irgendwie von lokal gezogen
Man konnte doch irgendwie...
Oh, das finde ich jetzt wieder.
Driver, Docker, Container.
Man konnte irgendwo
Plattform angeben.
Hier, minus minus Plattform.
Genau, ich weiß halt nicht,
ob das bei Docker Run
auch funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah.
Okay.
Arm 64?
Ja, das will ich ja gerade nicht.
Boah, das ist ja eklig.
Ja, das unterstützt Docker ja auch.
Man kann Docker irgendwie sagen, führe einen...
Fragen nochmal.
Docker run arm64 image on AMD64.
Das geht. Das mache ich auf meinem Raspberry Pi auch.
Ja, das habe ich doch gerade schon angegeben.
Das habe ich doch gerade schon angegeben.
Ja.
Aha.
So was gab es da doch hier.
Hey, das ist jetzt weg.
Eben war das noch da.
Okay.
Joker, run.
Multi-Arch.
Boah, kein Blasenschimmer, Alter.
Also ich habe das jetzt gesetzt.
Also ich würde sagen, so geht es eigentlich.
Ja, der sagt jetzt...
No such...
Ach, Moment, no such file or directory.
Wartet mal.
Wir gucken jetzt gerade mal.
Hier, Webserver Latest, Bin Bash.
Minus, Minus, Plattform.
Ne, also das habe ich schon mal nicht richtig gestartet hier.
Da muss man mal in die Hilfe-Datei gucken.
Also hier, Docker run.
Also, Docker run.
Was?
Ja, two examples.
Okay, aha, so muss man, das muss man machen.
Warum auch immer.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen, Docker run.
Ja, oder hier, keine Ahnung.
No matching, Dick, jetzt gibt's nicht.
Eurer perfekte.
Okay, das stimmt nicht mehr, was ich hier angebe.
Plattform.
Jetzt geht's.
Das war das richtige Kommando.
Ja.
Hello from Z-Servers.
Okay, aber ganz im Ernst,
Das ist ein super krasses Nischen-Ding, was der hier benutzt, ne?
Dass du mit Docker andere CPU-Architekturen ausführen kannst.
Ich benutze das tatsächlich auf meinem Raspberry Pi.
Ich lasse auf meinem Raspberry Pi ein AMD64-Binary bauen für Weekly-Builds.
Da mache ich das auch.
Wobei ich das dort irgendwo anders gemacht habe
Weil ich bilde mir ein
Dass das mittlerweile sogar in den Standard-Paket-Repos
Drin ist, dieses Docker-Multi-Arch-Ding
Das mache ich dann nicht so wie hier
Aber das war eine
Also das würde ich jetzt nicht
Das würde ich nicht Medium
Einsortieren
Und auch nicht als so, wie soll man sagen
Kann man wissen
Also das ist super Nischenkram.
Die Aufgabe hier mit der Multi-Art.
Also das ist krasses Nischenkram.
Es ist langsam, Xenpy.
Also es ist wirklich lahm.
Ich glaube, der Compiliert drei Stunden bei mir, der Raspberry Pi.
Ich mache der aber nachts irgendwann.
Wen juckt's?
Und auf dem Desktop kompiliert er, keine Ahnung, zwei Minuten?
Gut, wenn du es auf Macross kompilierst, hast du mehr Power.
Auf dem Raspberry Pi ist er lahm, ne?
Und Chat, wie war der Stream heute?
Haben wir mal wieder richtig high-IQ-Linux-Content gemacht?
Die Tage machen wir weiter.
wir müssen ja noch alle Medium-Aufgaben
erledigen und auch
noch die schweren Aufgaben.
Warum haben wir hier eigentlich gefailt? Das haben wir doch
geschafft das letzte Mal.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Die Grunde kann ich mich sogar noch dran erinnern.
Kann das sein,
dass ich das einfach nicht rechtzeitig, dass ich nicht auf
haben wir abgeschlossen
geklickt habe?
Wahrscheinlich.
Da müssen wir es einfach nochmal machen.
Aber Setzfam ist eine
richtige
Pogu-Seite.
MongoDB-Replikas.
Ich ahne ja schon ganz
furchtbar schlimme Sachen.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
die mache ich echt ungern.
Wie zum Beispiel
Zertifikatshandling.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt mittlerweile sogar
Business Only.
Das finde ich jetzt aber wiederum
nicht so toll, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich finde ganz ehrlich, mit einem Pro
Plan sollte man Zugriff auf
alle Szenarien haben.
Dass es extra Business Sachen gibt,
weiß ich nicht. Das finde ich jetzt nicht so toll.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Pro Plus
Moment, ich hab nen Pro Plus
Moment, ich müsste nen Business abschließen
dass ich die zwei Szenarien machen
Ja, ist klar
Darf ich das run?
Ne, das finde ich nicht gut
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde nicht gut
dass es Szenarien gibt, die nur für Business-User sind.
Wobei, wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr, was ich mir vorstellen kann, warum es das gibt?
Vielleicht ist es doch gar nicht so blöd.
Vielleicht sind das zwei Szenarien, die sehr explizit gemacht haben für Vorstellungsgespräche
und die wollen nicht, dass die Leute, die schon zu Hause üben können.
Und wer holt sich für ein Vorstellungsgespräch einen 250 Dollar Set-Servers-Account, ja?
Die wissen ja gar nicht, dass sie das machen. Das wäre ja nur auf gut Glück.
Bastelstream?
Ja, machen wir bestimmt demnächst auch mal wieder.
Das glaubt es wird sein.
Excellent.
Power off.
Bam.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder.
Wie gehabt.
Zwischen
Weiß nicht, 8.30 Uhr, 9.30 Uhr, vielleicht sogar 9.30 Uhr eher, wenn ich vorher noch eine Runde rennen gehe, weil dann ist es halt schön kühl.
Du könntest einen ESP32 mit Display machen, der dich an Sellout erinnert.
Sellout-Counter.
Hast du eine Idee?
Sekunde.
Hast du eine Idee, wie man sein Smart TV ins Heimnetzwerk am besten einbindet?
Ich habe mein Smart TV gar nicht ins Heimnetzwerk gepackt.
Der ist gar nicht am Netzwerk.
Ich habe eine...
Ich habe ein Shield TV an meinem Smart TV.
Und das hängt ganz normal im internen Netzwerk per RJ45-Stecker.
Aber wirklich im internen Netzwerk.
Smart TV habe ich nicht verkabelt.
Aber was ist dein Problem?
Also sprich, warum kannst du...
Weil der nur WLAN kann oder was?
Kann das sein?
Oder was ist das Problem eigentlich mit dem TV?
Oder denkst du,
dass ist da irgendwelches
Hersteller-Spionage-Zeug drauf?
Was durchaus sein kann.
Dann mach den besser aus.
Ja, Xoyo, das muss man jetzt schon noch schreiben.
Dann sag ich auch noch was zu.
Problem hab ich keins.
Ich bin nur am überlegen, wie ich es sinnvoll mache
wegen des ACR-Krams.
Tja.
muss mich mal unten was ist ac er kam was ist was ist ac adobe acrobat reader
dann eher nicht
ich weiß nicht was acs aber in der automatic content recognition und das
willst du nicht oder wie ich weiß so ganz verstehe ich verstehe ich es
problemlich
warum kannst du nicht einfach ein rj45 stecker in ein fernseh fernseher stecken
von einem switch
Weil das irgendwelche Sachen lokal auswertet, oder wie?
Also sprich, du willst nicht, dass der dein Netzwerk scannt nach Content und sowas.
Oder dann hängen doch ins WLAN, falls du ein eigenes WLAN hast.
Okay, okay, das verstehe ich.
Kannst du den ins WLAN hängen, wenn du ein eigenes WLAN hast?
Ansonsten...
Bleibt dir wahrscheinlich nicht viel übrig?
Hast du einen faulanfähigen Switch?
Ansonsten, wenn du eine Fritzbox hast oder so, Gäste-WLAN und den da reinhängen.
hat dns sperren wird ich mich nicht darauf verlassen
Ich meine, die Holzhammer-Methode geht natürlich immer.
WLAN aus plus Nvidia Shield.
Ja, das würde ich, also Nvidia Shield ist top.
Gibt auch noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Ich meine, wenn du Sachen blocken willst, dass das Ding...
Ja gut, aber wenn das ins Internet kommt, du willst ja damit Internet Access, dass du Firmware-Updates machen kannst, oder?
Ansonsten stecken halt einfach gar nicht ans Ding.
Weil wenn du darauf Apps verwendest, sowas wie Netflix und sonst was, dann brauchst du ja Internet-Access.
Also.
Dann ist ein Proxy mit irgendwelchen... Proxy? Proxy dazwischen?
Mit irgendwelchen Blocklisten oder so?
Wobei es halt die Frage ist, ob das über einen Proxy gescheit läuft.
Ob man überhaupt einen Proxy setzen kann.
Deswegen habe ich Nvidia Shield TV dran
Ich wollte meinen Fernseher auch
Ich habe meinen Fernseher erst gar nicht ins Netzwerk gepackt
Einfach Shield TV dran und gut ist
So, aber jetzt haue ich wirklich ab, Leute
Wir hören uns morgen früh
Bis denn, see you